Nein, nein, nein. Nein, nein, nein.
Nein, nein, nein. Rousseau, Frank Rieger, Chaos Computer Club Berlin.
Nein, nein, nein.
Viele unter euch werden diesen etwas ungewöhnlichen Start in den Blue Moon auf Fritz schon kennen. Es ist der letzte Mittwoch im Monat. Was bedeutet? Es gibt Chaos Radio auf Fritz, die Sendung, die vom Chaos Computer Club bestritten wird. Heute gesplittet, wir sind sehr, sehr modern und quasi in ganz Deutschland unterwegs. Na ja, ganz Deutschland wäre gelogen, aber zumindest bekommen Chaos Computer Club Mitglieder heute aus Hamburg und aus Berlin. Mein Name ist Max Formalotki und ihr stellt euch am besten selber vor.
Guten Abend, ich bin Aaron, wie gesagt aus Hamburg. Freue mich schon auf meine Rückfahrt heute Morgen, alle früh und wird wohl eine kurze Nacht werden.
Ja, ich bin Frank aus Berlin und habe mich vielleicht schon gelegentlich hier gehört.
Das Thema heute Abend, da hat man vielleicht aber noch nicht so viel drüber gehört, denn es ist, naja, welcher Natur kann man fast gar nicht sagen. Es ist philosophischer Natur, es ist medienkritischer Natur, es ist welcher Natur noch?
Was willst du sagen, Frank? Na, ein fundamentaler Natur kann man schon sagen. Also das Thema heute Abend ist die Wahrheit und was wirklich passiert ist. Also wir wollen heute ein bisschen versuchen, zu untersuchen, so ein bisschen aus unserer Erfahrung heraus. Ron und ich waren lange Jahre Pressesprecher des Chaos Computer Club und hatten da viel mit Medien und mit dem Aufbauen von Geschichten und Wahrheit zu tun und haben da mittlerweile ein bisschen Zeit gehabt, darüber zu reflektieren und wollen da vielleicht heute Abend ein bisschen mit euch, den Hörern, darüber reden und vielleicht auch ein paar von unseren Erfahrungen erzählen.
Genau, die Erfahrungen, die Sorteerfahrungen, die man dann gut beurteilen kann, wenn das alles schon ein paar Jahre her ist.
Genau.
Ist schon ein bisschen schwierig zu fassen, wenn man das so mit einem Halbsatz formuliert. Die Wahrheit und was wirklich passiert ist, was ja im Grunde suggeriert, wir haben einerseits die Wahrheit und wir haben das, was die Medien als Wahrheit verkaufen, wenn man so möchte, und auf der anderen Seite das, eben was wirklich passiert ist. Wie kann man so was aufschlüsseln, wenn man jetzt noch überhaupt keinen Zugang dazu gefunden hat?
Das werden wir versuchen darzulegen.
Ja, das ist leider ein bisschen umfangreicher. Das ist leider nicht so, ohne weitestimmend einen Halbsatz zu machen. Also, darüber reden wollen sind so die Konzepte und Mechanismen, die so um diese ganzen Begriffe Geschichten, Wahrheit, Informationen, Medien und auch Wissen gehen. Also, die versuchen, ein bisschen hinter zu gucken, welche Kategorien stecken dahinter. Und so, wenn wir uns die Geschichten angucken, dann fällt uns auf, dass wir damit so verschiedenen Gruppen von Geschichten zu tun haben. Es gibt halt immer wieder so Sachen, die man so relativ einfach identifizieren kann, als die sind ein bisschen komisch. Das sind halt so Geschichten, die es irgendwie übrigens um die Welt machen, die aber eigentlich keine Faktenbasis haben.
Ja, immer wieder schöne Beispiele. Also, man kennt sie auch als Urban Legends. Das sind diese Sorte Geschichten, die irre gut in den Zeitgeist passen, die man glaubt, ohne darüber auch nur eine Sekunde nachzudenken, die man ohne Face Value, wie der Engländer sagen würde, als Wahrheit akzeptiert. Es gab zu den Zeiten des E-Business-Hype und Internet diese wahnsinnig komische Geschichte, oder was heißt eigentlich, war die nicht sehr komisch, war die Geschichte des toten Start-up-Mitarbeiters. Die hat es bis in die New York Times geschafft, was ja ein relativ angesehenes Blatt ist. Und da ging es eben darum, dass am Samstag eine Putzfrau in einem Büro einen Mitarbeiter auf einem Stuhl hat sitzen sehen vor einem Bildschirm und ihn gefragt hat, was er denn hier macht in aller Herrgott-Früh-Hobst, ob es denn schon so schlimm sei. Und da ist er wohl tot vom Stuhl gesackt. Und das Problem war, der war schon die ganze Zeit tot. Und zwar irgendwann seit Freitagnachmittag. Und dann ging die Geschichte halt so weiter. Man hat dann die Mitarbeiter interviewt, die haben erzählt, naja, der Markus, wie er hieß, der war halt immer der Erste und immer der Letzte. Und er ist auch nie mit zum Mittag gekommen und hat immer viel geklotzt. Und so und letztendlich, ich weiß nicht, ich habe die E-Mail glaube ich, also diese Geschichte in meiner E-Mail gehabt, mindestens dreimal, immer mit so Kommentaren wie, mach mal nicht so viel, dreh mal ein bisschen zurück und so. Weil das ja klar war, die Leute in diesen Start-ups, die haben alle zu viel gearbeitet, die ganzen Nerds. Diese Nerds, die haben sowieso mit dem Social-Life nicht so viel am Hut und so.
Und die New York Times, war es die New York Times oder? Wahrscheinlich. Hat die eine Geschichte darüber gebracht, dass diese Geschichte nicht wahr war oder hat die Geschichte tatsächlich genau so gebracht, nach dem Motto, die fallen alle vom Stuhl, weil sie nicht mal Mittagessen gehen?
Also die Geschichte war nicht nur New York Times, sondern in diversen anderen Medien tatsächlich als irgendwie eine wahre Geschichte berichtet.
Genau, die ist richtig um die Welt gegangen.
Die ganzen Boulevardblätter haben da irgendwie natürlich, ich meine, das ist halt eine Geschichte, die passt natürlich zu so was wie einer BZ oder einer Bildzeit und klar, also eine ähnlich gute Geschichte ist dieser Untergang von Tuvalu. Das ist eine Insel im Südpazifik, glaube ich.
Genau, in der Nähe von Neuseeland.
Genau.
Und so ein kleiner Staat, so ein Naturinselstaat.
Genau, also da hat es so einen Hügel Sand im Meer halt.
Genau, mit Holtling und so.
Und die sollte halt untergehen durch irgendwie die globale Erwärmung.
Genau, globale Erwärmung wissen wir alle, passiert, findet statt. Der Meeresspiegel steigt wegen den Gletschern, die alle schmilzen und deswegen gehen die unter. Und das ist alles ganz grauenhaft und es sind mehrere, keine Ahnung, 10.000, 100.000 Leute betroffen. Und der Staat Neuseeland hat sich schon gesagt, wir nehmen die hier alle auf und die werden hier alle Bürger und so, find fein.
Ja, nur es war halt nicht so. Also ich meine, jeder hat es erwartet, also sozusagen es passt irgendwie in das, was halt irgendwie... Passt ins Bild.
Wir haben die globale Erwärmung, die Meerestänge, Spiegel steigen alle.
Man weiß, dass diese Inseln flach sind, also sind die halt irgendwann weg.
Muss ja so sein.
Genau, klar, kann nicht einer sein. War halt leider auch nicht wahr. Ja, so Geschichten gibt es halt so einige. Also eine der schönsten Geschichten ist halt diese Kausings-Ship-Geschichte. Die gibt es in vielen Varianten. Irgendwie die letzte war irgendwie irgendwo über einem größeren Gewässer in der Nähe oder um Russland, wo ein Fischerboot von einer vom Himmel fallenden Kuh versenkt wurde.
Genau, die fischen da fröhlich vor sich hin und plötzlich kommt die Kuh vom Himmel gerast, knallt durch das Schiff, macht ein großes Loch rein und die saufen fast alle ab. Natürlich ist einer übrig geblieben, der hatte die Geschichte erzählt von der Kuh.
Genau, die Investigation hat dann halt herausgefunden, dass es sich dabei offenbar um durchgeknallte russische Soldaten handelte, die eine Kuhhärte geklaut haben mithilfe eines Transportflugzeuges und denen sind halt die Viecher ein bisschen durchgedreht irgendwie beim Transport, weil sie auch nicht angeschnallt waren und dann mussten sie die halt unloaden von oben und genau haben sie die Klappe aufgemacht, bevor sie die Kuh auf dem Schoß hatten.
Kann man ja nachvollziehen und da wir alle wissen, dass die russische Armee nichts zu essen hat, ist es völlig klar, dass sie Kühe klauen gehen und dass sie die natürlich ohne anzuschnallen in den Transporter scheffeln oder so und genau und dann versenken sie damit Halsschifferboote, F-Fischerboote. Das Interessante an der Geschichte ist halt, dass sie nicht zum ersten Mal aufgetaucht ist. Die Frage ist natürlich jetzt, wann werden wir das nächste Mal von toten Start-Up-Mitarbeitern oder Ähnlichem lesen, also von Echoes dieser Geschichte, von dieser Geschichte, aber diese Echoes von dieser Kuh, die vom Himmel fällt, das findet man schon immer wieder alle paar Jahre.
Ja, das kommt immer wieder vor. Es sind halt richtige Urban Legends.
Genau, gibt es inzwischen auch Bücher, die sich damit beschäftigen. Und Webseiten natürlich. Das ist die Kategorie 1. Kategorie 1 der Geschichten. Geschichten, die es um die Welt machen, aber eigentlich gar nicht wahr sind. Und da gibt es die Kategorie 2. Das sind die Geschichten, die viel mehr werden, als es die Fakten selber hergeben. Ja, da gibt es auch viele schöne Beispiele, klassische Beispiele, die wahrscheinlich auch wesentlich bekannter sind, als diese Geschichten mit dem toten Starterwütter weiter. Das sind Geschichten wie das Schicksal von Marilyn Monroe, gerade erst wieder im Spiegel aufgeliehen.
Oder Kennedy zum Beispiel. Wurde Kennedy nun umgebracht und von wem? Oder Diana natürlich. Diana ist auch irgendwie ein sehr, sehr schönes Beispiel für so eine Geschichte. Ja, und das sind halt so Geschichten, die halt so eine gewisse Seite zum Schwingen bringen in vielen Leuten, die halt eine persönliche Betroffenheit auslösen und die, wo die Faktenbasis eigentlich irgendwie einigermaßen trivial ist, da ist halt irgendjemand irgendwo umgekommen. Auf irgendwie mehr oder minder natürlich Art und Weise. Und derjenige war nun halt ein bisschen berühmter als andere Leute, aber die Art und Weise...
Naja, oder irgendwas. Also Berühmtheit ist sicherlich ein Punkt. Aber wir werden später noch dazu kommen, was sind eigentlich die Punkte, die diese Geschichten ausmachen. Aber hier ist es ja sicherlich eins, dass es einfach nicht nicht ertragbar ist, dass eine Prinzessin, schön, jung und so weiter, einfach so in einem Verkehrsunfall, ganz platt gesagt, stirbt.
Das ist doch banal.
Das kann gar nicht sein.
Das geht nicht. Da muss es irgendeinen sinistrenen Hintergrund geben.
Wobei, da kann ich ja mal kurz zwischengrätschen, weil das von der Überschrift her würde mir das ja eher gefallen. Das ist Kategorie 2. Geschichten, die mehr werden, als es die Fakten hergeben. Ist es nicht so, dass man gerade bei den Geschichten eben halt möchte, dass die Fakten Menge größer wird und dass man eben mehr über die Geschichte erfährt, weil einem diese Person wichtig ist und aus welchem Grund auch immer. Also ob sie nur eine Persönlichkeit ist, ob man sie mag, ob man sie als Fan ist oder so. Die Fakten sind halt nicht genug und deswegen, gerade deswegen möchte man halt mehr darüber wissen und deswegen bleibt es im Gespräch.
Genau, die Fakten sind nicht genug. Es gibt sozusagen einen Bedarf an mehr Fakten. Da gibt es einen Markt. In dieser Markt muss dann befriedigt werden.
Mit Geschichten quasi.
Und im Zweifelsfall mit Geschichten. Ich erinnere mich an einen Anruf, den ich hatte zu der Zeit. Als Sprecher des TCC kriegt man ja viele seltsame Anrufe in der Woche. Und ich habe das erst gemerkt, wie viele das eigentlich waren, nachdem ich damit aufgehört habe. Als das Telefon dann plötzlich nicht mehr so viel klingelte. Das war schon eine echte Erfahrung.
Kannst du dir dann auch irgendwie unwichtiger vor?
Hm, geht so.
Egal, der Anruf war, hier ist eine Journalistin, von der irgendwie eine Zeitschrift Kategorie Bunte, und meinte, ob ich mich denn auskennen würde mit HIRF, GANS und ähnlichen Geschichten. Also das sind dann nur High Energy Radio Frequency. Genau, vielen Dank Frank. Das sind Geräte, mit denen man sozusagen Computer beraten kann, und zwar aus der Ferne. Ich stelle mich irgendwo hin, nehme meine HIRF-GUN, zeige die auf den PC oder was auch immer, drücke drauf, dann macht das so ein bisschen Britz, und der Computer ist halt platt, weil er sozusagen gegrillt wird auf die Ferne. Also eine Art Mikrowelle, wenn man will, ganz platt gesagt. Und da meinte ich, naja, so viel weiß ich darüber nicht, eigentlich ist da der Frank, der Spezialist, und da kann ich gern durchstellen, aber worum geht es denn überhaupt? Und dann waren, ja, wie mobil die denn seien. Diese Hörfguns. Meine Neujahrung kommt darauf an, wie groß der Computer ist, den man grillen will, und so sieht man halt entweder aus wie die Ghostbusters, und hat so einen Rucksack auf und so ein Rohr in der Hand. Oder man braucht schon einen ganzen Lastwagen voll mit Equipment, wenn man den Großrechner im, weiß ich nicht, zweiten Stockwerk unter der Erde Platten machen möchte. Aber die gibt es schon transportabel. Ja, ob die denn wohl auch gegen Autoelektronik funktionieren würden? Ja, möglicherweise kommt auf die Autoele, wenn wir nennen die Autos, sind dann wieder Mikroprozessor gesteuert, heutzutage immer mehr und so weiter. Ja, und in diesem Bremssystem, und ob denn da schon Mikroprozessoren drin wären, und ob denn das auch gegen fahrende Autos funktionieren würde. So, und dann erst fiel natürlich bei mir der Groschen, das hat echt lange gedauert, und dann meinte ich, na ja, so gesehen schon selbstverständlich, gerade wenn der Rechner läuft, also das Auto fährt, würde sowas auch funktionieren, und meinte ich dann gleich weiter, und das funktioniert sicherlich auch, wenn man auf einem Motorrad sitzt und hinter einer schwarzen Limousine hinterher fährt, durch einen Tunnel durch, und in der schwarzen Limousine sitzen Prinzessinnen. So, und dann wurde es sehr still auf der anderen Seite.
Und, hast du dich dann in der bunten wiedergefunden, bzw. der bunten Alternative, oder haben sie es dann gelassen?
Naja, ich hab mich dann rückversichert, mit Frank gesprochen. Wir haben uns darauf geeinigt, dass das zwar ganz grundsätzlich vielleicht nicht völlig unmöglich ist, aber denn doch so extensive Spuren hinterlassen würde, dass man da eigentlich das nicht unter den Teppich kehren kann.
Also die Motorelektronik wäre halt einigermaßen zusammengeschmolzen.
Wobei ich es bewundernswert finde, dass diese Frau überhaupt diesen Begriff kennt und dieses Gerät.
Ja, also wie sie auf die Geschichte gekommen ist, das würde mich auch mal... Vielleicht hat sie Win Schwatter irgendwo gelesen.
Ja, vielleicht. Also letztendlich kann man schon sagen, da hat jemand echt nach Fakten gegraben oder nach Dingen, die so aussehen, als könnten sie Fakten sein für eine coole Geschichte.
Durchaus kreativ. Also ich find ja sowas... Also klar, wenn es jetzt nicht in dem Zusammenhang gewesen wäre, hätte ich gesagt, geile Verschwörungstheorie, wer sich sowas ausdenkt, der hat echt was im Köpfchen. Weil das halt so nahe aneinanderzubringen, was eigentlich überhaupt nicht zusammengehört, das ist ja der Trick dabei.
Ich bin gerade am überlegen... Keine so schlechte Journalistin.
Ich bin gerade am überlegen, ob das das Jahr war, wo auch so ein paar angebliche Erpressungsversuche ließen.
Ja, das war die Geschichte... Ja, stimmt, das war das Jahr, in dem es irgendwie Geschichten gab darüber, dass angeblich in London irgendwelche Russengangs losziehen und Banken erpressen mit EMPs. Also EMP sind halt so elektromagnetische Pulsbomben, die halt in der Lage sind, Computer zu zerstören oder zumindest so zu stören, dass sie nicht mehr ordentlich funktionieren. Und da gab es die Geschichte, dass mit solchen Geräten angeblich russische Gangster oder wie auch immer durch die Gegend ziehen und Banken erpressen sagen, entweder er gibt uns ein paar Millionen Pfund oder wir zünden so ein Ding vor eurem Rechenzentrum. Und dass die angeblich auch etliche davon gezahlt haben sollen. Die Geschichte war in, wie ist unser Lieblingsblatt für solche Stories? War es die Sunday Times?
War das nicht in so einem großen Blatt?
Ja, es gibt doch eins von diesen Blättern, die irgendwie am Sonnenamt erscheinen und die irgendwie viel seriöser klingen, als sie eigentlich sind. Das kann gut sein. Aber jedenfalls, ja, das war irgendwie, ja, das war die Geschichte, die gerade im Umlauf war. Zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Vielleicht sollten wir jetzt zur Kategorie 3 kommen. Die sogenannte traurige Kategorie.
Nee, die Kategorie, wo man als, ich sag's mal, ganz frech, intellektueller mal, sich immer so schön aufregen kann, wenn sie es denn nicht um die Welt schaffen. Fakten, die es verdient haben, wo der natürliche Lauf der Geschichte oder wie auch immer verlangt von den Dingen, dass sie Frontpage, erste Seite, großer Aufmacher.
Und sich Leute richtig aufregen.
Und die Leute müssen sich eigentlich richtig aufregen.
Und was passiert, passiert genau nichts.
Oder Seite 4, abstruse Artikel. Wenn wir Glück haben.
Mal eine Seite im Spiegel.
Genau, eine Seite im Spiegel. Wenn wir mehr Glück haben, großartige Diagramme, also großformatige, nicht notwendiger, sind großartige, großformatige Diagramme in der Zeit, die dann so, wer die Zeit kennt, weiß wie groß ist das A1 oder was, wenn man die ausklappt, A2. Und dann aber beide Seiten belegen. Und dann so Diagramme, so Punkt A nach Punkt B, A und C und F und D und dann mehrfarbig, weil man mit nur schwarz-weiß und Pfeilen das gar nicht abbilden kann. Dritte Dimension, Farbe dazu. Und dann ist nur noch völlig unklar.
Ja genau, solche Geschichten sind halt so, irgendwie sowas wie diese Spenden-Skandale. Die waren halt irgendwie in der Zeit auf irgendwie ein großes Diagramm oder Leuna. Leuna war auch so eine Geschichte.
Wo sie den Geldfluss versucht haben abzubilden oder abgebildet haben, mehr oder weniger vollständig. Und dafür irgendwie einfach A1 oder A2, was das ist, gebraucht haben.
Das sind halt Geschichten, die sind halt einfach zu komplex.
Genau, Geschichten, die es nicht um die Welt machen, obwohl es die Fakten hier geben sollten. So. Was fällt uns da noch ein?
Ja, die Sachen mit der momentanen Volkszählung zum Beispiel. Richtig. Es gibt ja momentan eine Volkszählung, von der irgendwie niemand weiß.
Genau.
Und zwar die sogenannte Datenbank-basierte Volkszählung, wo halt einfach der Staat sich langsam die Berechtigungen zusammengeklaut hat, um einfach über eine Auswertung aller Daten, die er eh schon über den Bürger registriert hat, in eine neue Volkszählung zu machen. Das heißt, wenn die ganzen Melderegister, die Arbeitslosen, Daten und so weiter und sofort zusammengeführt, sodass niemand tatsächlich mehr irgendwelche Fragebögen ausfüllen muss, wo halt irgendwie Fragen draufstehen, die man vielleicht lieber nicht beantworten möchte. Sondern es ist halt einfach so, dass man halt einfach nur so direkt aus der Datenbank ausgefüttert wird. Und dann gibt es halt noch einen Mikrozensus, wo halt irgendwie ein paar Leute noch genauere Fragen beantworten müssen, um halt die Unschärfen rauszukriegen.
Die schleichende Volkszählung sozusagen.
Genau.
Und interessiert es irgendjemand? Weiß es irgendwer? Was war das für ein Alarm vor wie vielen Jahren ist das hier? Was war das für ein Alarm? Unterschriften sammeln, sich überlegen, ob man in den Knast geht oder nicht. Wenn man diesen Fragebogen nicht ausfüllt, wat nicht noch? Und jetzt findet es statt. Besser, effizienter. Schöner für die, die die Daten haben wollen. Und interessieren tut keiner. Thema ist durch, abgelaufen, die Welle ist vorbei oder so.
Wobei, das ist ja wirklich ein Phänomen, wo sich kürzlich auch die Journalisten wieder darüber aufgeregt haben, dass aufgrund gerade sowas wie Sommerloches, was wir momentan wieder beobachten können, wo sich dann natürlich die Politik momentan reindringt, deswegen ist es nicht so ganz so krass, aber dass es wirklich so ist, dass diese Schwellen, diese Schwellen beim normalen Menschen abgebaut werden. Wenn irgendwas schon mal in der Zeitung war, ist das Interesse, sich dann nochmal darum zu kümmern, viel, viel geringer und dass jedes Mal wird es weiter abgeschurbelt und wenn da nicht wirklich noch ein anderer Aspektron ist, wird es nicht mehr angenommen.
Ich kenne die Theorie anders, ehrlich gesagt. Ich dachte, wir mussten uns damals nach dem großen Mir-Unfall auch noch alle anderen kleinen Mir-Unfälle und ob es ihnen wieder gut geht und ob die Toilette wohl oben jetzt gerade funktioniert oder nicht. Alles in den Nachrichten, in den 20 Uhr Nachrichten anhören, weil das Thema halt einmal da war und wenn es einmal da war, wird es gerne nochmal wieder genommen.
Ja, wobei das hängt, glaube ich, davon ab, ob es eine Story ist, die man so weiter erzählen kann. Das ist nämlich immer das Problem. Es gibt nämlich Stories, die kann man nicht so weiter erzählen. Da ist quasi nochmal genau der gleiche Einzelfall aufgetreten. Nach dem Motto, der Alligator ist aus dem Zoo ausgebrochen, hat das kleine Kind gefressen. Da würden sich die Leute daran erinnern, dass sie es vor fünf Monaten schon mal gehört haben. Also kommt das nicht auf die Eins. Und das gibt es mit allem. Das gibt es auch mit politischen Ereignissen und diese Komplexität. Da würde ich gerne allerdings nochmal nachhaken. Warum können Geschichten eigentlich zu komplex sein? Wie funktioniert das?
Na ja, es gibt halt einfach mehrere Aspekte. Sie können einerseits nicht zu dem passen, was die Leute glauben. Also was ihr Bild von der Welt ist. Da kommen wir später nochmal drauf. Und zum anderen können es einfach so sein, dass sie so komplex sind, dass sie einfach nicht mehr zu vermitteln sind. Dass du sie nicht mehr in irgendwie zwei Spalten Bildzeitung unterbringen kannst.
Ich denke über diese, warum sind die einen Geschichten so und die anderen so. Da sollten wir uns gleich drüber unterhalten. Und vorher sollten wir mal fragen, was habt ihr denn so erlebt da draußen?
Ja, in der weiten, wilden, fiesen, medial vermittelten Welt. Das wäre sehr, sehr spannend. 033170-971110 ist unsere Telefonnummer heute Abend für den Blue Moon Chaos Radio auf Fritz. Und vielleicht solltet ihr so ein bisschen in euch gehen, weil man verdrängt sowas sehr gerne, weil diese Geschichten haben einem in der Regel ja überhaupt nicht gefallen. Vielleicht sollten wir gerade bei Kategorie 3, der traurigen Kategorie, nochmal ansetzen, um da euch das ins Gedächtnis zu rufen. Geschichten, die es nicht um die Welt machen, obwohl es die Fakten hergeben sollten.
Genau, irgendwas, was ihr mitgekriegt habt oder vielleicht ein bisschen involviert wart. Und das hätte es doch eigentlich mindestens in die Zeitung machen müssen, vielleicht auf Seite 1, und dann ist es da nicht gelandet. Das wird uns interessieren.
033 171 97 91 10. Wo habt ihr wirklich gedacht? Das hätte ich echt gerne weiterverfolgt gewusst. Und Tatsache ist, aufgrund irgendeiner anderen dummen Geschichte, die sich gerne auf eins setzt, wie zum Beispiel so einem Alligato, der ein Kind frisst. Gut, der hat das Kind gefressen, schade um das Kind, armer Alligator und so weiter. Aber man hätte vielleicht gerne was über die neue Abwehr gewusst, okay? Ja, muss man sich nicht weiter aufregen, da kann man ja einfach dann noch warten. 0331 77 97 1 1 0, wenn ihr euch in die Diskussion einschalten möchtet, könnt ihr anrufen. Und wir werden uns die kommenden zweieinhalb Stunden, gute sind es noch, damit weiterhin beschäftigen. Im Studio der Ron aus Hamburg vom Chaos Computer Club und der Frank aus Berlin, meine Person Max von Malodki. Der Vermittler zwischen den Wegen sozusagen. Ich, ähm, solange wir hier mal warten und gucken, ob sich jemand meldet. Barschel habt ihr gar nicht gesagt. Barschel hätte ich ja auch spannend gefunden. Das war nämlich das, wo ich immer mehr darüber hätte wissen wollen.
Barschel war auch wieder so eine Geschichte, die halt wirklich viel zu komplex war, wo es halt einfach unglaubliche Mengen Beteiligte gab, die halt irgendwie tausend Interessen hatten. Der hat eigentlich auf richtig vielen Hochzeiten getanzt, dieser Barsche. Und es gab halt einfach hinten raus, zumindest in der Darstellung von dem, was in den Medien angekommen ist, so viele Leute, die ihn irgendwie möglicherweise loswerden wollten, dass man sich im Zweifel nicht für einen entscheiden kann.
Wobei das ja auch eine Verteidigungsstrategie eines der Beteiligten gewesen sein kann. Aber ich denke, da kommen wir nachher noch zu. Was dazu geführt haben kann, dass manche Geschichten auch komplex gemacht werden. Dann denkst du, das ist eigentlich ganz einfach, oder? Und dann kommen plötzlich drei und sagen, nein, da gehört dies noch dazu und jenes noch dazu. Dann müsste man noch beachten, dass ist da auch eine Verbindung hierhin und dorthin. Und dann schalten die Leute ab. Was, worum, wohin geht das noch, mit wem, was, wie viele Verbindungsknoten bis dann irgendwie und so.
Ja, so wird es manchmal wirklich gemacht. Wir haben den ersten Hörer am Telefon. 0373 97 91 10. Wenn ihr auch anrufen möchtet. Der Arne aus Köln. Hallo, Arne.
Ja, mir geht es um das Thema PGP-Verschlüsselung.
Kannst du es kurz erklären für alle, die es nicht so wissen, was es ist?
PGP ist eine Technik, mit der man zum Beispiel oder hauptsächlich E-Mails verschlüsseln kann und damit halt verhindern kann, dass diese E-Mails von Leuten manipuliert oder gelesen werden und man irgendwie auch spioniert wird.
Das, von dem sich Otto Schiehli wünscht, dass alle der deutschen Wirtschaft das momentan auch dann auch machen. Ja, weil ich, also ich erinnere mich nur, das ist jetzt aber was anderes, weiß nicht, ob du darauf hinaus willst. PGP, also dieses PGPI, das Ganze wurde ja irgendwie eingestellt, die Seite und so. Das Ganze wurde verkauft und dann wurde es eingestellt und dann hat sich Otto Schiehli überlegt, dass die Bundesregierung doch bitte ein eigenes Programm auflegen möchte, damit man dem entgegenarbeitet und Deutschland ein eigenes Verschlusslungsprogramm hat.
Ja, ich wollte eigentlich auf den ersten Punkt hinaus und zwar, dass es eingestellt wurde. Und soweit ich weiß, ist ja die amerikanische Regierung mit drin in dieser Sache, dass das irgendwie verdrängt wird.
Ich weiß nicht, ob dir die neuesten Entwicklungen bekannt sind. Also PGP Inc. gibt es wieder. Und zwar haben offenbar die Manager, die bei Network Associates damals das Management von PGP gemacht haben, sich halt Venture Capital gesucht und die Rechte von PGP gekauft und bringen im November eine neue Version von PGP raus.
Genau, einer der Chefentwickler ist dabei und Phil Zimmermann ist wieder dabei. Genau, Phil Zimmermann ist wieder dabei. Das ist Good News. Aber um PGP ranken sich ja auch extrem viele Geschichten. Das ist ein schönes Beispiel. Und du hast was verpasst. Und zwar weil Phil Zimmermann auf der letzten Veranstaltung der niederländischen Hacker Hacking at the End of the Universe, war das das, Frank? Oder Hacking at Large? Shit, ich krieg's noch nicht hin. Egal, auf der letzten Veranstaltung der niederländischen Hacker, also sowas ähnliches wie das Chaos Communications Camp, nur halt in Holland, war Phil Zimmermann und hat erzählt aus, keine Ahnung, wie lange er jetzt schon PGP macht, aus, keine Ahnung, 10 Jahren PGP oder so. Und die E-Mails, die er da kriegt mit so diesen Fragen, sag mal Phil, jetzt unter uns, ist eine Hintertür drin oder nicht? Ja, kannst du dir das vorstellen, du kriegst solche Mails, es gibt Leute, die fragen ihn das und erwarten eine Antwort. Ja, und erwarten vor allen Dingen nicht beschissen zu werden. Ja, also wenn es eine Hintertür gäbe, würde es ihn sagen. Und er meint irgendwie, er wäre zwischendurch sehr versucht, er würde immer auf seinen Fingern sitzen, dann immer auf seinen Händen sitzen, damit er nicht mehr schreibt wie, okay, ich vertraue dir, dir vertraue ich, es ist keine drin. Und nur so Geschichten mehr, die da immer weitergehen. Ich erzähl noch eine, weil das echt witzig ist. Und zwar gab es einen Riesenaufstand, als PGP gekauft worden ist von, war das NAI. Frank? Ich glaube NAI und NAI dann weitergemacht hat mit der Entwicklung. Und NAI war in so einer Koalition drin von Leuten, die in Anführungsstrichen an einer Standardisierung für Hintertüren gearbeitet haben. Und Phil Zimmermann hat das nicht gewusst. Er hat dann E-Mails gekriegt, wieso lasst ihr euch kaufen von Leuten, die in dieser Allianz für die Hintertüren drin sind, habt ihr nicht mehr alle Tassen im Schrank, kann ich mit der nächsten Version rechnen, dass da auch eine Hintertür ist, zertifiziert nach Standard oder was? Und er hat das dann schon irgendwie, hat das nicht gewusst, er hat dann bei den Managern angerufen, bei NAI und die haben es auch nicht gewusst. Die sagen, in was für einer Allianz sind wir drin? Niemals, haben wir nie unterschrieben. Und dann haben sie nachgeprüft und festgestellt, NAI ist in keine Allianz eingetreten per Unterschrift, sondern sie haben eine Firma gekauft, die in der Allianz drin waren. Und daraufhin hat diese Allianz gesagt, na ja, so gesehen ist dann ja auch jetzt NAI bei uns Mitglied, oder? Ein toller Name mehr auf unserer Webpage. Ja, und haben das irgendwie fröhlich veröffentlicht. Ja, ich meine, solche Sachen, die kann ich sehr gut glauben, weil sie klingen so richtig nach, so sind Leute eben. Unfälle passieren und keine Verschwörungstheorie weit und breit. Und der Witz war, die haben dann da angerufen und gesagt, wir wollen aus eurer Allianz aussteigen, und die haben gesagt, na gut. Aber im übernächsten Update von der Webseite dieser Allianz waren sie dann wieder gelistet. Und dann haben sie irgendwann aufgehört, dann haben sie rausgekriegt, sie zahlen da irgendwie Beiträge, dann haben sie diese Beiträge stonniert und dann hat das noch ein halbes Jahr gedauert und dann waren sie erst von der Webseite runter.
Schön. Ah ne, nette Geschichte, oder? Dann nehmen die mal mit zurück nach Köln, wir wollen nämlich jetzt Nachrichten machen. Vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Hoffentlich Allianz versichern.
Wenn Fritz rund um Cottbus, dann 103, 2.
Tierzeit halb elf. Mit dem Wetter, nachts, örtlich Schauer und Gewitter, um 16 Grad am Tag dann wieder, oh man, bis 30 Grad. Und jetzt die Meldungen mit Kerstin Topp.
Der frühere südafrikanische Präsident Mandela hat die internationale Gemeinschaft aufgefordert, den freien Zugang zu Wasser zu einem Menschenrecht zu erklären. Regierungen und Unternehmen müssten dieser Frage höchste Priorität einräumen, sagte Mandela auf dem UN-Gipfel für nachhaltige Entwicklung in Johannesburg. Derzeit haben mehr als eine Milliarde Menschen keinen Zugang zu sauberem Trinkwasser. In Deutschland haben sowohl Regierung als auch Opposition einen Militärschlag gegen den Irak abgelehnt. Bundeskanzler Schröder und Außenminister Fischer sagten, Deutschland werde sich daran nicht beteiligen. Unionskanzlerkandidat Stoiber warnte die USA vor einem Alleingang. Das Entscheidungs- und Handlungsmonopol in dieser Frage liege bei den Vereinten Nationen. Die deutschen Hofwassergebiete bekommen bis zu 12 Milliarden Euro Unterstützung von der EU. Das Geld soll überwiegend durch Umschichtungen innerhalb der bestehenden Förderprogramme verfügbar gemacht werden. Es wird aber auch günstige Kredite geben. Gegen den ehemaligen Finanzdirektor der US-Firma Worldcom ist formell Anklage erhoben worden. Vor einem Bundesgericht in New York wurde der 40-jährige Sullivan wegen Fälschung von Firmendokumenten und Wertpapierbetrugs angeklagt. Ihn drohen bis zu 25 Jahre Haft und eine hohe Geldstrafe. Und noch zwei Meldungen vom Sport. Zunächst mal Fußball. In der ersten Runde des DFB-Pokals verlor Tennis Borussia Berlin gegen den Zweitligisten St. Pauli mit 1 zu 2 und zum Tennis. Die Pleitenserie der deutschen Tennisspieler bei den US Open in New York ist beendet. Der Mannheimer Alexander Pop kam in die zweite Runde. Er schlug den Schweden Andreas Vinzigerda in 3 Sätzen. Die Verkehrsmeldungen A100 Stadtring Berlin, Berlin-Wedding, Richtung Glichtenberg. Zwischen Anschlussstelle Hohenzollern-Damm und Autobahn 3 Gewöhmersdorf stockender Verkehr. Und nochmal A100 Stadtring Berlin, Berlin-Wedding, Richtung Berlin-Wöhmersdorf. Die Anschlussstelle Kurfürstendamm Schwarzbacher Straße ist wegen Wassers auf der Fahrbahn gesperrt.
Sie ist unterwegs, sie macht Spaß.
Und ganz bestimmt irgendwann kommt sie auch zu dir. Die Fritz Disco. Samstag, 31. August, 22 Uhr beim Dorffest in Kroppen mit den Fritz-DJs T-Bird und Der Rizzler. Special-Gest Jan-Wayne. Mehr Infos.
Und ihr hört immer noch Chaosradio auf Fritz. Immer den letzten Mittwoch im Monat mit dezenter Klavierbegleitung im Hintergrund. Wir befinden uns nicht in einer Bar, obwohl wir das gerne wollten. Und der Ron sucht einen Knopf.
Der drückt uns alle Kniffe und es flutscht eine lustige Kleiderin.
Nimm mal den ganz rechts, Ron. Hallo, Ron.
Jetzt hören wir dich wieder.
Aber ich hör nix.
Du hörst nix?
Dann nimm noch den daneben vielleicht auch noch.
Aber wir hören dich. Nee, eigentlich hören wir dich. Vielleicht hat sie, die Kerstin war ja vorher an deinem Kopfhörer, den einfach wieder leise gemacht. Das kann gut sein. Unten so am Holz, also quasi unter der Tischplatte. Ach, das ist toll. Jungs dazu haben die sich so gut mit Technik auskennen und dann an sowas verzweifeln. Das ist menschlich, das finde ich gut. Genau.
Das sind analoge Schieberegler. Ich will gar nicht wissen, was du willst.
Stichwort Technik. Es gibt für die Leute, die das Thema auch ein bisschen komplex finden, immer jeweils so die Sachen, worüber wir reden, gibt es auf der Webseite. Die URL der Webseite ist chaosradio.ccc.de slash Wahrheit. Nochmal chaosradio.ccc.de slash Wahrheit.
Da ist kein WWW davor.
Genau, kein WWW davor, um alle zu ärgern, die WWWs mögen.
Und für den Fall, dass ihr nicht telefonisch unter 033 177 97 110 in der Diskussion teilnehmen möchtet, sondern lieber tippt, dann bietet sich an, E-Mail-Variante zu wählen. Und zwar 75, weil es die 75. Chaosradio-Sendung ist, 75 at chaosradio.de, wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Ich glaube ja.
Aber Anruf ist natürlich auch gefragt. Und wir haben vorhin drei Kategorien dargestellt von Geschichten, die naja, ihre eigene Art von Wahrheit im Grunde propagieren. Können wir vielleicht noch mal kurz darlegen, warum es sich da handelt, weil wir auch schon tiefer in der Diskussion waren. Damit die, die neu anrufen möchten, auch wissen ungefähr, worum es geht.
Wir haben einmal so die Geschichten, die es so rings um die Welt machen, aber die eigentlich keine wirkliche Faktenbasis haben. Also das sind halt so lustige, kleine Geschichten, die halt meistens so als Urban Legends auch bekannt sind. Also sowas wie von der Kuh, die irgendwie den Fischkotter versenkt hat oder von dem Startup-Mitarbeiter, der tot an seinem Schreibtisch saß oder von der Südseeinsel, die irgendwie von der globalen Erwärmung verschlungen wird.
Und Geschichten, die mehr werden, als es die Fakten hergeben. Geschichten, die an sich banal sind. Prinzessin stirbt bei Verkehrsunfall und die dann unglaublich groß werden. Die Leute motivieren, nach mehr Fakten zu suchen, nach einem tieferen Sinn dieses tragischen Unfalls etc.
Ja, und dann haben wir noch die dritte Kategorie von Geschichten. Das sind die, die es nicht um die Welt machen, also die nicht irgendwie sozusagen zu einer Geschichte werden, die sie jeder sofort erinnert, weil sie halt zu komplex sind, weil sie zu schwierig sind, die aber eigentlich von der Faktenbasis ziemlich interessant sind, sowas wie Barschel, wie der Spenden-Skandal, wie Leuna, wie die schleichende Volkszählung. Ja, und was wir von euch gerne hören wollen würden, ist, ob ihr auch noch so Geschichten habt. Wie war die Telefonnummer?
033 77 97 11 0, die muss man sicher nicht nur wirklich merken können. Das ist ziemlich lang. Im Studio Ron und Frank vom Chaos Computer Club und Max von Malodki. Und am Telefon ist der David aus Kleinen Machnummer. Hallo David.
Ja, hallo.
Guten Abend. Was ist deine Geschichte?
Also meine ist zum dritten Thema. Und es geht um Tunnesien. Das war jetzt ungefähr Anfang dieses Sommerferiens, dass da irgendwo Anschläge auf Hotels waren. Und das war eben, zufällig haben wir, also meine Familie, das gelesen in der Zeitung, also in der Kleinen Anzahlung stand, irgendwo mittendrin in der Zeitung.
Naja, stimmt, die Geschichte wurde ganz schön runtergekommen.
Ja, und das war eben der Problem, das war sehr schlecht, weil nicht so war, dass wir nämlich in Tunnesien da ein Hotel gebucht haben. Und nämlich genau in der Nähe von einem Hotel, das eben evakuiert wurde, weil es nämlich eine Warnung da gab, dass da eben vielleicht ein Anschlag wäre. Und es war nur eine Warnung, und mehr danach nur das, was gehört. Und nicht, ob da irgendwas passiert ist, oder nicht passiert ist, was da nun gemacht wurde jetzt später, ob da ein Anschlag war, ob dann später noch wichtig kam, kam gar nichts mehr. Es wurde einfach die Information dazu abgebrochen.
Naja, ich meine, es gibt dann halt auch irgendwie mächtige Interessen, die irgendwie gerade keine Anschläge in Urlaubsgebieten brauchen können, so TUI und Ähnliches. Also da, das sind so Geschichten?
Das wäre wichtig, weil zum Beispiel wir wollten ja wieder hin und haben gerade deswegen die Urlaube abgebrochen. Und hätten wir vielleicht noch vorher, bevor wir abgebrochen hätten, die Urlaub noch was erfahren, dass doch gar nichts passiert da, dann hätten wir vielleicht die Urlaub noch weiter gemacht.
Das heißt, du hast dich aufgrund des Mangels an Fakten oder Informationen oder Coverage durch die Press dafür entschieden, nicht hinzufahren?
Das war also nicht nur meines, sondern von meiner Mutter, weil die eben die Angst hat, dass da was passiert. Und deswegen haben wir entschieden, dass wir nicht hingehen. Und wäre es vielleicht bessere Informationen gewesen, dass es doch ganz sicher nicht ist, dass nichts passiert, dann wären wir hingegangen.
Bis zu welchem Punkt kann sich so ein, also es ist natürlich jetzt Spekulation, aber bis zu welchem Punkt könnte sich so ein Reiseveranstalter wirklich durchsetzen, dass solche Geschichten nicht an die Öffentlichkeit kommen? Ist das große Macht?
Naja, ich meine, man muss einfach noch mal gucken, wie viel in den entsprechenden Magazinen zu entsprechenden Zeiten Anzeigen von solchen Reiseveranstaltern drin sind. Das ist dann halt, also danach richtet sich dann die Macht bei der jeweiligen Zeitung.
Ja, das ist aber die Verentwörungstheorie dahin.
Ach.
Muss ja mal irgendwie fragen, wie große deutsche Unternehmen mit ihren Anzeigen umgehen, wenn gerade Geschichten kommen, die ihnen nicht passen. Ist durchaus üblich. Also das kann ja irgendwie jeder Anzeigenverkaufsleiter eigentlich bestätigen.
Frank, da du gerade mal ein Weltbild zerstörst, hört es in jeder Zeitung zu sein.
Geht das eigentlich auf den Radiosender?
Trink Coca-Cola jetzt sofort an dieser Stelle!
Entschuldigung, habe ich irgendwas gesagt, habe ich nicht aufgefallen. Ja, sehr, sehr, sehr schade. David, wohin geht es denn dieses Jahr in Urlaub?
Dieses Jahr noch eigentlich gar nicht mehr. Ich denke erst mal nicht weg, weil ich jetzt meine zusätzlicherweise meine Ausbildung beginne und da eben weniger Freizeit haben werde. Deswegen denke ich dieses Jahr nicht mehr als nächstes Jahr wieder.
Na dann viel Spaß, vielleicht entdeckst du ja wieder was.
Und ich wollte noch sagen, ich hätte vielleicht noch ein drittes Thema, ein viertes Thema schon, ein viertes Thema, was eben noch wäre, wo man noch nachforschen könnte. Zum Beispiel werden so Geschichten, die wo man nicht mehr weiterforschen sollte, weil das dann zu bestimmte Leute angreifen würde, das wäre furchtbar, wäre vielleicht nicht toll für die. Da wären so kein Fakten raus, die eigentlich keiner erfahren sollte.
Das sind halt diese Geschichten, die wir in dieser dritten Kategorie, also Geschichten, die es nicht um die Welt machen, obwohl die Fakten eigentlich interessant sind.
Die wir eben nicht machen sollten, auch diese Geschichten, die wir auch machen und nicht machen sollten.
Na wer ist denn derjenige, der bestimmt, dass diese Geschichten es nicht machen sollten?
Also ganz im Ernst, vielleicht hat ja jemand bei deiner Urlaubsgeschichte da, also mit dem Anschlag in Tunesien, entschieden, dass das als eine von den Geschichten sein soll, die es nicht um die Welt machen.
Na gut, aber ich könnte schon verstehen, also was ich darunter verstehe, wäre zum Beispiel sowas, dass sich die Boulevardpresse auf irgendjemanden stürzt, der irgendwas Kleines gemacht hat, was für den relativ unwichtig ist, aber das wird so aufgeblasen, dass diesem Menschen sein Leben zerstört wird. Das wäre eine Geschichte, wo ich zum Beispiel sagen würde, da wäre es nicht so toll, dass da unbedingt weiter geforscht wird, in dem Sinne, dass dieser Mensch einfach weiter sein Leben leben kann.
Gut, okay, das ist aber... Ja, okay, ich verstehe, was du meinst, sozusagen Geschichten, die es zwar gibt und die zwar möglicherweise, das was da berichtet wird, auch irgendwas mit dem zu tun hat, was tatsächlich geschehen ist, nur wo es eigentlich so unwichtig ist und irgendwie der Schaden so groß ist, dass berichtet wird, dass man sie überall bleiben lassen soll. Ja, das stimmt, das ist richtig, das ist ein interessanter Ergänzer.
Und da wollte ich nur sagen, dass meine ich, dass eben diese Geschichten besser nicht gemacht werden sollten.
Hau, ich muss eine kleine Korrektur vornehmen. 75.chaosradio.ccc.de Ja, wir reden hier von einer Subdomain. 75.chaosradio.ccc.de Das ist ein echter Techie, Mann! Ja, toll, wir haben hier extra für euch einen kleinen Kurs gemacht. Das wäre die E-Mail-Adresse, wenn ihr noch was schreiben wollt, weil wir haben vorhin das noch ein bisschen verkürzt dargestellt, das ist nicht wirklich wahr. 75.chaosradio.ccc.de So soll es gut sein für die nächste halbe Stunde mit dieser E-Mail-Adresse. Telefon ist angesagt.
Können wir noch die URL nochmal sagen, nämlich chaosradio.ccc.de slash Wahrheit, das ist die URL zur Sendung.
Und der Philipp ruft an. Hallo Philipp.
Hallo.
Guten Abend. Was ist deine Geschichte?
Ja, meine Geschichte ist die dritte Kategorie, also gehört zur dritten Kategorie. Und zwar ist es so, es ist eine Geschichte, die eigentlich an Dauer passiert, wahrscheinlich mehrmals am Tag. Und zwar war es so, ich war in einem Restaurant, hab da gegessen und vor meinen Augen hab ich gesehen, wie plötzlich eine Frau erstochen wurde. Und ja, es ist halt so was. Das kam in die Lokalzeitung, das ist in Bayern passiert, kam in die Lokalzeitung, aber sonst nichts. Und ich denk mal, so was, das kommt nicht weiter, weil das halt jeden Tag passiert und deswegen eigentlich kein Schwein mehr interessiert. Und das würde sich zum Beispiel auch für die Presse und für die Medien gar nicht lohnen, sowas weiter zu verbreiten.
Ja, kann sein. Wobei man sich natürlich die Frage stellt, warum schaffen es manche Erstecherungsversuche in die Presse und andere nicht. Na klar, ich meine, wenn berühmte Personen betroffen sind, dann reicht schon der Versuch, jemanden zu erstechen für, naja, am mindestens Seite drei. So wie neulich wieder bei Lisa noch gleich an meinem Rollstuhl. Schäubelchen. Bin ich heute schlecht mit Namen. Genau, Schäubel. Schäubel. Schäubel, der gerade wieder angegriffen worden ist.
Das interessante Bit gar mit der Geflügelschere, was echt irgendwie originell war.
Auf ne Art. So, und da war jetzt gerade in England, in England war gerade, weiß ich nicht, zwei Wochen oder so am Stück, elf Tage oder so, Wahnsinns-Media-Coverage, weil da zwei Mädchen weggekommen sind, elf und zwölf Jahre alt oder so. Das war jeden Tag, in jeder Zeitung, auf der ersten Seite. So, und ich glaube, am dritten oder am vierten Tag kamen dann so ein paar Leserbriefe, die sagten, aber hör doch mal zu, das passiert hier jeden Tag in diesem Land. Und dann so ein paar Fallbeispiele aufgezählt. So, und dann natürlich der Vorwurf, woran liegt das jetzt, dass die beiden Mädels es auf die Frontseite machen und die ganzen Jungs, die jetzt aus irgendwie Londoner Vorstadt kommen, möglicherweise farbig sind, Randgruppe, sozial schwach. Und die da verschwinden, dass das überhaupt nicht, das schafft es vielleicht in den Lokalteilen.
Du weißt den Grund?
Ich denke mal, das ist so, weil die Sachen verschieden spektakulär sind auch. Wenn zwei kleine Mädels entführt werden und umgebracht werden, das ist irgendwie was, das passiert halt doch nicht so oft. Und es geht halt um unschuldige Kinder sozusagen, während in Anführungszeichen einfacher Mord halt wirklich viel öfter passiert und nicht so spektakulär.
In dem Fall ist es aber du hast wahrscheinlich recht. Letztendlich, es gibt sozusagen Vorstadtkinder, die sind dann, wenn ich dich jetzt mal ganz hart beim Board nehme, vielleicht nicht unschuldig oder was? Wenn die anderen sind unschuldig, heißt das, dass die anderen nicht unschuldig sind und so. Na klar, die beiden Mädels, sie kamen aus einem verschlafenen Nest, wo sich alle wirklich sicher gefühlt haben, schon voll klar. Vorstadt, so eine riesen Großstadt, ist natürlich gefährlicher, weiß ja jeder und so.
Also diese Frage, wieso, welche Kriminalfälle es auf die Titelseite machen, da gibt es interessante Untersuchungen zu. Tatsächlich, die Fotogenität des Opfers ist ein wesentliches Kriterium. Also Opfer, die halt irgendwie kein tolles Foto machen, kommen in der Regel nicht in die Zeitung.
Die überhaupt erst mal Fotos machen, muss ja Kriterium Nummer eins sein.
Ja klar, also es gibt halt tatsächlich irgendwie, bei der Boulevardpresse gibt es halt eine Spezies von Reportern, die da auch Leichenfletterer genannt wurden. Deren Aufgabe ist es halt irgendwie zu den Hinterbliebenen oder Eltern oder was auch immer zu gehen und denen halt ein Foto aus dem Familienalbum abzuluxen. Und die gehen dann halt Eisenhardt mit dem Spruch hin, pass auf, wenn du willst, dass irgendwie wir deine Tochter finden können, mit Hilfe der Zeitung gib uns ein schönes Foto. So gehen die dahin. Und natürlich geben die Eltern der Zeitung ein Foto.
Wobei das natürlich auch Hand in Hand spielt, insofern als der Begriff, der ja gerade viel und vom, Moment, Sekunde, vom Philipp, dass die süß seien und die anderen nicht süß seien, dass die süß sind, ist ja nur der Eindruck, den ich gewinne, weil ich in der Zeitung ein Bild sehe, wo die auch süß gemacht wird. Das ist halt der Punkt. Sonst würde ich die nicht süß nennen. Wenn die da dargestellt ist, wie die ihren Bruder verprügelt, würde ich halt sagen, wow, was für ein Beast.
Das ist halt, das ist auch, glaube ich, eines der Probleme, was die Amis hatten, dass die ersten Fotos von Bin Laden halt einfach echt sympathisch aussahen.
Ja, das kann gut sein. Also was ich mich gefragt habe, als diese Fotos veröffentlicht worden sind, von diesem Typ, der dieses Massaker in der Schule angerichtet hat. Wo war das noch gleich?
Erfurt.
In Erfurt.
Schäuble war übrigens der.
Danke schön, das war der Politiker, nicht der, der das Massaker angerichtet hat. Genau. Da ist ja das Foto, das die ersten zwei, drei Tage durch die Presse gelaufen ist, das war nicht sehr vorteilhaft. Das war sogar richtig unvorteilhaft, wenn man das mal mit den Fotos verglichen hat, die dann später irgendwie mit Spiegeln überhaupt auch an anderen Stellen aufgetaucht sind. Da hab ich mir auch gedacht, wer sucht dieses Foto aus? Nach welchen Kriterien ist das ausgesucht worden? Ist das das erste Foto, das die Eltern rausgerückt haben? Kann ich mir fast nicht vorstellen.
Naja, die Sachen machen es halt tatsächlich um die Welt, die halt zu einer guten Geschichte machbar sind. Also, dass denen man halt tatsächlich irgendwie eine Story machen kann, die passt.
Aber was ich finde, was Philipp ja auch angesprochen hat, was auch ein Problem ist, wenn du jeden Tag alle Kinderentführungen, Kindermorde und so weiter, alles, was wirklich stattgefunden hat, in der Zeitung lesen würdest, dann würde sich ratzfatz sowieso keiner mehr dafür interessieren.
Der interessante Punkt ist, dass die...
Ja, oder das würde einen Fass zum Überlaufen bringen.
Der interessante Punkt ist, dass die tatsächlich der Anzahl von solchen Fällen zumindest in Deutschland relativ gering ist. Also es ist halt tatsächlich irgendwie, selbst wenn es irgendwie, sag mal, irgendwie 200 oder 300 Fälle im Jahr sind, ist es zwar absolut gesehen eine hohe Zahl, die halt irgendwie echt eine Menge Leid beinhaltet, so, aber die tatsächliche Chance, Opfer eines solchen Verbrechens zu werden, ist trotzdem immer noch gering. Und das sind halt, also, was halt passiert ist, dass die Presse halt die Perspektive verschiebt. Und dieses Perspektiven verschieben geht halt gut, wenn es halt eine gute Geschichte ist. Da ist dann letztendlich einigermaßen irrelevant, was wirklich passiert ist, sondern wichtig ist, dass es tatsächlich eine gute Geschichte ergibt.
Aber wenn wir es ad absurdum treiben, dann muss ich dich fragen, weißt du, dass diese Zahlen, die du da hast, wirklich stimmen?
Kann ich nicht sagen.
Wer weiß, ob diese Polizeistatistiken wirklich stimmen? Wer weiß, wie viele von überhaupt entdeckt werden von den Entführungen? Wer weiß, wie viele überhaupt angezeigt werden? Wie viele Dunkelziffern gibt es? Das ist so was, wenn du da wirklich bis auf den Boden gehst, weißt du nichts mehr. Das ist nämlich das Problem dabei. Und das ist lustig, finde ich.
Ja, ein sogenanntes Weltbild.
Ja, damit räumen wir heute gründlich auf im Blue Moon auf Fritz Chaos Radio. Wir haben noch gute zwei Stunden Zeit.
Hat mir gut getan, dass ich das mal loswerden konnte.
Ne, also mal abgesehen davon. Ich meine, wir reden jetzt hier sehr auf einer Meter eben darüber und kümmern uns jetzt nicht darum, dass Mord im Grunde eine eklige Sache ist und so. Aber es ist schon schlimm, da Zeuge zu sein. Das sei jetzt mal ungenommen. Boah, ist schon hart, wenn man da drüber so auf so einer cool, cool Ebene edet, ne? So diese klassische journalistische, ah, wie viele Kinder werden da überhaupt entführt und ne und so.
Hochgradig zynisch. Hochgradig zynisch. Ich weiß nicht, ich hoffe, dass zwischendurch mein Sarcasmus gut rüberkommt. Sonst, ich kann ja hier kein Schild hochhalten, wo immer drauf steht, Saracosmos, Saracosmos, Saracosmos.
Also auch nicht kann ich beruhigen, denn Sarcasmus kommt hervorragend rüber.
Dann geht's ja.
So was sind das für Geschichten, ne?
Dieses Kohl-Zitat passt auch da ganz hervorragend. Von Herrn Kohl. Der hat mal gesagt, in einem Interview als Antwort auf einen Anwurf, sagt er, das ist eine klassische journalistische Behauptung. Sie ist zwar richtig, aber sie ist nicht die Wahrheit.
Ja, was eins zeigt, dass er den Unterschied begriffen hat zwischen dem, was die Wahrheit ist und das, was ist richtig ist oder das, was wirklich passiert ist oder wie man das auch immer nennen möchte. Letztendlich ist ja die Geschichte, mit dem wir es hier zu tun haben, oder so Wahrheit oder Nicht-Wahrheit, von wem hören wir die Geschichten? Wir hören die Geschichten aus den Medien, also von Journalisten, geschrieben von Menschen, die wir immer gern als objektiv bezeichnen.
Die sich gerne als objektiv bezeichnen.
Von denen man Objektivität unterstellt, von denen man Objektivität verlangt. Eigentlich. So, eigentlich. Aber das ist Quatsch. Ein Journalist will nicht objektiv sein. Ein Journalist hat kein Interesse daran, objektiv zu sein. Ein Journalist will eine Geschichte erzählen. Ich hab da zwischendurch eine schlechte Meinung von Journalisten gehabt. Man muss verallgemeinern, es ist falsch, aber es gibt aus meiner Sicht definitiv Journalisten. Genug von denen haben wir kennengelernt, oder habe ich kennengelernt in meiner Zeit als Pressesprecher für den CTC, die eine Geschichte im Kopf hatten und die nur noch bestätigt haben wollten. Da fängt man schon mal an zu denken, was ist so ein Journalist eigentlich für einen? Das ist ein Mensch, der möchte sich mitteilen, möchte Geschichten erzählen, möchte die Leute aufklären. Was ist das Problem von jemandem, der Leute aufklären möchte? Man muss diese Leute erreichen. Man erreicht Leute nur, wenn man wer ist eigentlich heutzutage.
Oder eine gute Geschichte hat.
Oder das Medium etwas ist.
Oder das Medium etwas ist, genau. Und wie kommt man in dieses Medium rein, wenn man eine gute Geschichte hat? Ohne gute Geschichte kommt man nicht rein. Und selber als Journalist ist man, wenn man, ich stelle mich hin und sage, ich bin Journalist. Und ich sage, die Weltlage ist die und die und die Politiker müssen das machen und das machen und das machen. Die lachen mich doch aus. Wenn ich keinen Namen habe, hört mir keiner zu. Was machen Journalisten? Also die Journalisten, die noch keinen Namen haben. Sie suchen sich Leute, die einen Namen haben. Und lassen sie ihre Geschichte, die sie sich vorher ausgedacht haben, belegen. Genau, noch mal erzählen. Die sind auf der Suche nach dem sogenannten O-Ton. Mit oder ohne Kamera, mit oder ohne Mikrofon.
Soundbites.
Genau, und wollen dann Soundbites haben. Von Leuten, die bitte schön einen Namen haben. Oder zu einer Organisation gehören, die einen Namen haben.
Oder denen man irgendwie guten Gewissens den Titel Experte ankleben kann.
Ganz genau. So, und mit denen haben wir ja viel zu tun gehabt. Da macht man schon die Erfahrung, da ruft einen einer an. Und hat dann eine Geschichte im Kopf. Und diese Geschichte möchte man bitte bestätigen. Und zwar möglichst knackig, mit möglichst schönen Soundbites. Damit er die Geschichte dann entsprechend verkaufen kann, platzieren kann und auch sein Geld verdient.
Wenn ich vielleicht als Journalist und Betroffener ganz kurz grätschen könnte und eine Verteidigungsrede vorbereitet. Es ist ja eine Unterstellung im Grunde klar. Es ist deine Meinung und so.
Es ist meine Erfahrung. Ich hab nicht nur eine Meinung, ich hab Erfahrung.
Ich bin Experte. Aber das, was wir daraus gelernt haben, ist auch, deine Meinung basiert auf deiner Erfahrung und kann sich deswegen keinerlei Objektivität anmaßen. Insofern macht man im Grunde selber den gleichen Fehler. Ich wollte nur gar nicht darauf eingehen.
Welchen Fehler?
Der Journalist, was versucht er? Es gibt natürlich welche, die sagen, ich habe mir hier ein Bild gemacht und ich möchte das gerne bestätigt sehen. Aber wie funktioniert der Mensch? Wenn ich eine Geschichte recherchiert habe, weiß ich so viel, wie ich über diese Geschichte weiß. Und wie gehe ich auf dich zu, wenn du der Experte bist? Ich erzähle dir erstmal, was ich weiß, um im Grunde weiter dir zu sagen, ich habe diese Basis an Wissen über diese Geschichte. Was weißt du darüber?
Genau, was weiß ich darüber? Ich habe mich oft mit Journalisten gefragt, ob das richtig ist. Dann haben wir gefragt, ob wir denken, dass das richtig ist, oder ob wir denken, dass das vielleicht falsch ist. Aber die Frage, die mir niemand je gestellt hat, glaube ich, ist, das ist das, was Sie gerade gesagt haben. Gibt es Leute, die anderer Meinung sind?
Da muss ich ein paar Leute unserer Zunft schon verteidigen. Es gibt welche, die genau das tun. Du bist nur ein reflektierter Mensch, und würdest vielleicht sogar sagen, es gibt den und den, es gibt den Frank, der anderer Meinung ist, oder so. Aber wenn du jetzt einen Professor anrufst von irgendeiner Universität, der belegterweise ein Buch geschrieben hat, das genau den Tenor besitzt, den du gerade da nachrecherchiert hast, dann würde der dir nicht sagen, da rufen Sie den Herrn Müller an, das ist mein Erzfeind oder so, sondern der würde dann auflegen. Und das möchtest du ja nicht. Du möchtest ja deine Quelle behalten. Und möglicherweise sagt dir deine Quelle im Endeffekt noch, hey, verpiss dich und du darfst das nicht drucken, was ich gesagt habe.
Naja, also was mich immer wieder fasziniert, ich führe diese Diskussion ja schon länger auch mit Journalisten, was mich immer wieder fasziniert, ist ja sozusagen die phenomenologische Betrachtung. Mir ist bisher nicht ein einziges Mal untergekommen, dass etwas, was ich zum Beispiel im Spiegel oder in anderen Zeitungen gelesen habe, von dem ich definitiv Ahnung habe, also wo ich wirklich richtig Bescheid weiß, dass das, was da drin stand, irgendetwas damit zu tun hatte. Das war entweder grob verfälscht, wesentliche Sachen waren weggelassen, es war irgendwie so hingestellt, dass irgendwie ein Teilaspekt der Geschichte, der tatsächlich irgendwie eigentlich total uninteressant ist, aber eine gute Geschichte ist, aufgebläht wurde und die gesamte Story wurde und so weiter und so fort. Es war tatsächlich so, dass der wesentliche Inhalt des Themas, also das worum es ging, dass das in der Regel nicht der Inhalt des Berichts war.
Na gut, da laufen natürlich mehrere Sachen zusammen. Wie arbeitet ein Medium wie der Spiegel? Was, das kann man ruhig so sagen, eines der am besten recherchierendsten Medienverbünde ist, wenn man so möchte, die es gibt. Das kann man ruhig sagen. Also sie recherchieren schon sehr, sehr gründlich. Wie machen die das? Wenn man sich so einen großen Artikel anguckt, der im politischen Bereich zum Beispiel angesiedelt ist, sind da immer mindestens acht bis zehn Leute beteiligt. Das ist nicht einer, der den schreibt in der Regel, sondern hinten dran kann man meistens sehen, sind sehr, sehr viele Leute. Die Multiplikation im Grunde, also diese...
Aber wie oft wirst du im Spiegel, die den Satz, das ist das, was alle, das was wir sagen, oder das was die meisten sagen, aber es gibt auch Leute, die sagen was anderes. Das letzte Mal hab ich diesen Satz im Economist gelesen, wo die sagen, wir sind der Meinung das, sie werden aber auch Leute finden, die der Meinung sind das.
Also das ist ein typisches Kennzeichen gerade von deutschen Medien, ist der Anspruch der objektiven Wahrheit. Ein Artikel erhebt immer den Anspruch, also Sedan ist tatsächlich ein Meinungsteil, aber ein Artikel erhebt in der Hegel, also gerade auf die politischen Artikel, im Spiegel erheben den Anspruch, die Wahrheit, also tatsächlich das, was passiert ist, darzustellen. Obwohl sie dazu ganz objektiv nicht in der Lage sind. Weil der Journalist kann ja von seiner Meinung nicht abstrahieren.
Also mehrere Sachen, diese Geschichte mit, es gibt auch eine andere Meinung. Normalerweise werden Artikel im journalistischen Bereich, wenn sie seriös recherchiert sind, in der Regel so aufgebaut, dass man sich Meinungen aus den verschiedenen Lagern besorgt, von denen man weiß, dass es sie gibt, oder von denen man innerhalb der Recherche erfährt, dass es sie gibt. Das heißt, ich lasse alle in diesem Beitrag zu Wort kommen, um im Grunde die verschiedenen Pole abzudecken und damit eine simulierte Objektivität zu erreichen. Das heißt, ich gebe alle Meinungen, damit diese Meinungen zusammen das objektive Bild ergeben, wenn derjenige alle Meinungen für sich zusammenführt.
Naja, das ist natürlich das, was man auf der Journalistenschule lang in der Realität passiert, ist natürlich, dass die Art und Weise der Präsentation der Meinungen der einzelnen Seiten tatsächlich eine Gewichtung des Artikels darstellt. Was gerade im Spiegel immer wieder wunderschön zu beobachten ist. Der letzte Absatz im Spiegel in diesen einseitigen Artikeln, das ist immer so richtig klassisch an dieser Stelle.
Da kommt halt der Punkt, und da wollte ich bei dir vorhin einsteigen, weil das ist das, was wirklich problematisch ist. Es spielten da einige Sachen zusammen. Das erste ist die Komplexität. Ihr seid in eurem Thema richtig fit. Jetzt bin ich der Journalist und möchte bitte, dass meine breite Masse, meine breite Leserschaft komplett verstehen kann, worum es in diesem Artikel geht. Also versuche ich runterzubrechen. Und dann kommt der zweite Stolperstein. Ich muss es möglichst interessant machen, damit die Leute es lesen. Und da kommt der Punkt, dass man dann die Geschichte herausfällt, die das meiste hergibt, weil an der möchte man es gerne aufhängen. Und das ist die Crocs.
Das kennen wir. Das haben wir alle mitgemacht. Da sind wir durch eine harte Schule gegangen. Da haben wir vor Kameras gestanden und der Journalist hat uns eine Frage gestellt. Und dann haben wir eine Antwort gegeben. Und dann hat er gesagt, okay, und jetzt machen wir das nochmal. Und zwar für alle. So, und dann haben wir noch eine Antwort gegeben. Und dann hat er gesagt, ah, schon besser. Und jetzt machen wir das nochmal. Und zwar eine Antwort für alle jetzt, bitteschön. So, und da muss man sehr aufpassen. Was man am Anfang versucht, ist, die gesamte Geschichte zu erzählen. Zu sagen, hör zu, das hat so und so viele Seiten, das kann man so betrachten, das so, das Nifty Detail ist dieses und jenes, ganz genau betrachtet und eigentlich gesehen. So, und irgendwann stellt man dann fest, Shit, das krieg ich nicht rüber. Ich muss also verkürzen. Und an der Stelle verliere ich Detail. Und in dem Moment, wo ich Detail verliere, verliere ich Fakten, Wahrheit, ein paar Ansichtsseiten. Und dann steht man natürlich, das haben wir ja auch erlebt, nicht? Das ist dann die Jungs wieder vom Chaos Computer Club, die Überflieger, ihr habt die im Fernsehen gesehen, die erzählen nur Scheiße.
Ja klar, weil soll ich dann das rausschneiden, im Zweifelsfall, wo ihr sogar mit den Deppen da steht.
Genau, und der Punkt ist interessanterweise, dass genau dieser Moment, in dem hab ich echt viel gelernt, in dem Augenblick, wo ich tatsächlich meine eigene Geschichte diesem Journalisten zuliebe auf zwei Sätze verkürzt habe, in dem Augenblick habe ich genau dieses Prinzip verstanden. Diese Geschichte mit den Stories, dass es nur um die Story geht. Und was ich noch sagen wollte, ich nehme es ja keinem Journalisten übel, dass er so vorgeht. Das ist sein Job. Nur, dann soll er es auch sagen. Verstehst du, wenn er...
Aber da kommen wir zum nächsten Punkt, und das ist, was ich noch ansprechen wollte, Relativierung. Wenn ein Journalist auf sein System eingeht, das heißt, wenn ich in jedem Artikel erklären muss, was ich hier weglasse, inwiefern ich kürze, zusammenfasse und so weiter. Das wäre im Grunde die Konsequenz, aber das können die Leute nicht wollen, weil dann würdest du die ganze Zeit immer sagen, aber das kann man nicht so sagen, weil, ne, ne, ne. Du würdest die ganze Zeit nur um dich rumschleichen.
Die Konsequenz ist, den Objektivitätsanspruch aufzugeben und einfach zu sagen, ich hab eine Meinung. Das ist zum Beispiel das, was der Economist tut. Der Economist sagt halt einfach, dieses Blatt ist der Meinung, dass wir Krieg gegen den Irak führen sollten. Und dann begründen sie das halt auch. Ihre Begründungen sind teilweise schlecht. Man muss da nicht mit ihnen einer Meinung sein, aber zumindest ist klar. Genau dasselbe Blatt stellt sich zum Beispiel hin und sagt, dieses Blatt ist der Meinung, dass aus volkswirtschaftlichen Gründen Drogenprohibitionen wirklich abgeschafft werden sollte. Und wir vertreten diese Meinung seit 1984.
Und so weiter und so fort. Und den Rückschritt zu machen und zu sagen, das zuzugeben und es auch ab und zu mal einfließen zu lassen, ich bin gar nicht objektiv. Ich habe ja diesen Vorwurf oder meine Betrachtung oder meine Erfahrung, dass Journalisten arme Würstchen sind, die gerne Geschichten erzählen wollen, weil ihnen niemand zuhören würde, wenn sie das unter ihrem eigenen Namen machen würden. Zitieren sie immer Leute, die wichtig genug sind, dass man dann der gesamten Geschichte glaubt, dass man sie liest, ihr zuhört, wer auch immer. Habe ich mal auf dem Journalistentag im Gruner & Jahrhaus in Hamburg vorgebracht, in einer Podiumsdiskussion und da habe ich es aber gekriegt. Ist klar, also das so. Aber, und das war richtig witzig, nach der Veranstaltung kam einer und nahm mich so ein bisschen zur Seite und meinte, stimmt, ist so. Es gibt Journalisten und viele, viele, die sind so. Und dann meinte er, ich bin Fotojournalist, ich mache Fotos.
Ja, da ist es aber auch.
So, ja, genau, da ist es aber auch. Und da meinte er, na ja, guck mal, ich kann zu so einer SPD-Veranstaltung gehen und ich kann zwei Objektive einstecken, Weitwinkel und mehr so die Tele-Variante. Und dann kann ich mit meinem Foto mindestens zwei Aussagen machen über eine Veranstaltung, nämlich sie war gut besucht oder sie war schlecht besucht. Wenn ich der Meinung bin, diese Veranstaltung war schlecht besucht, dann setze ich mich ganz hinten in den Saal, nehme irgendwie das Weitwinkel und fotografiere so, dass ich möglichst viele Leere rein auf dem Foto habe. Dann habe ich die unterschwellige Aussage, es war niemand da. Was heißt das? Das kann nicht so gewichtig gewesen sein. Das heißt, viele Leute lesen den Artikel dabei gar nicht, der neben diesem Foto steht. Oder ich gehe irgendwie vorne ran oder fotografiere über alle paar Köpfe, die da sind, Richtung Sprecher, damit das so aussieht, als wären da viele Leute.
Oder wie ist es auch die hübsche Frau in der dritten Reihe?
Genau. Und damit manipuliere ich massiv. Und ich behaupte, es gibt genug Fotojournalisten da draußen, die das nicht reflektieren.
Ja, aber die Frage ist ja, wie fotografiere ich objektiv mit meinem Objektiv?
Na, kannst du nicht. Geht nicht. Du musst dir halt dessen bewusst sein, dass du nicht objektiv sein kannst. Wie gesagt, glaube ich, genau dieses Problem, was da entsteht, ist, dass die Leute gerade in den Journalistenschulen diese Objektivitätsethik eingebläut bekommen. Und auch versuchen zu erhalten. Es ist ja nicht so, dass die alle durchgeknallte Zyniker sind, sondern es ist ja tatsächlich so, dass da durchaus noch eine Menge Leute sind, die halt versuchen und zumindest die ersten zwei, drei Jahre irgendwie diese Ethik aufrechtzuerhalten, bis sie verstanden haben, wie der Hase läuft.
Oder ihr Leben lang. Ja, aber auch.
Es gibt halt, wird dir wahrscheinlich manchmal auch die Möglichkeit nicht gegeben, es gibt welche, die aus Versehen ihr ganzes Leben das machen und dann auch nur bei Medien arbeiten, die ihnen im Grunde das erlauben. Es gibt halt Medien, die das nicht erlauben, weil sie andere Stories möchten.
Genau, das sind dann die ganz harten, die einen aus dem Kontext heraus zitieren, also die eine verkürzte Aussage nehmen, aus dem Kontext rauslösen und dann zitieren, dass das eine völlig andere Aussage ist, weil sie im Artikel in einen anderen Kontext gesetzt wird. Ich hab auch schon erlebt, dass das große...
Wirtschaftshafen war das, ne?
Naming Names was soll's. Einfach falsch. Einfach in Anführungsstriche Sachen gesetzt, nie gesagt.
Zitater erfinden, das war immer unser liebstes Problem, so was wir da so hatten in der Pressearbeit.
Eine letzte Sache möchte ich da noch anbringen, weil ich ja mal Sprachwissenschaften studiert hab, ich geb's zu, und zwar gibt's ja noch eine Ebene, die sehr interessant ist, und zwar die der Sprache an sich. Denn wenn ich etwas schreibe, welche Worte muss ich benutzen, damit ich objektiv schreibe? Denn wenn ich schreibe, benutze ich meinen Wortschatz und alles hat eine Färbung automatisch. Die meisten Sachen haben eine Färbung. Wenn du objektiv schreiben willst, ist es sich doch so steril an, das würde keine Sau lesen. Also fängst du an schön zu schreiben und wenn du schön schreibst, färbst du.
Nein, das ist nicht richtig. Das ist nicht richtig. Das Problem ist, dass ich das schwierig... also jetzt wird es richtig komplex. Auf das Thema Sprache kommen wir gleich noch. Und wer aber der englischen Sprache gut mächtig ist, der möchte mal gucken unter www.generalsemantics.com oder.org oder.net oder so. General Semantics, wie generelle Semantics. Da gibt es ein paar sehr schöne Aufsätze über Sprache, über die Verwendung von bestimmten Wörtern, über die Verwendung des Wortes ist, ist als Definition, ist als Information, ist als Manipulation und so weiter. Da wird man feststellen, dass man schön schreiben kann, ohne sofort immer Wertung einfließen zu lassen. Es ist echt sau schwer.
Es war jetzt auch nicht so gedacht, dass dieser klassische perfekte Text, sondern dass ich in meinem Sinne, also im persönlichen Sinne des Journalisten, der halt seinen Stil hat, schön schreibe. Und wenn der sich das so vorstellt, dann geht er automatisch Kompromisse ein. Also der schreibt nicht schön nach diesen Stilen, die da wahrscheinlich vorgegeben sind, sondern eben halt für sich schön. Und das ist halt immer eine Gratwanderung im Grunde.
Diese Sachen mit der Sprache finde ich insofern wichtig, als wie die Mechanismen funktionieren, mit denen es durchgesetzt wird. Ich hatte mal die Gelegenheit, die Redaktion der Bildzeitung zu besichtigen und festzustellen, wie da dieser Bildzeitungsstil durchgesetzt wird. Es ist nicht so, dass die den Leuten einen Style Guide geben oder so, sondern die machen es tatsächlich wirklich, machen irgendwie den Prinzip der Auslese. Es gibt ja den sogenannten Galgen. Und jeder einzelne Artikel, der in dieser Zeitung erscheint, mit Ausnahme des Sportteils, aber ansonsten komplett alles, geht auf diesen Galgen. Da sind die drei stellvertretenden Chefredakteure und gucken jeden einzelnen Artikel an und tun ihn ins Layout und kürzen ihn zurecht. Und wenn er ihm nicht passt von der Sprache her, dann geht er einfach zurück an den Journalisten mit der Maßgabe entweder kürzen auf dieses Format oder Sprache anpassen ohne Spezifiker. Und das ist tatsächlich so, dass die haben auch die Macht, jeden Artikel umzuformulieren. Da hat der Journalist nichts mehr mit zu tun. Der liefert nur rohen Text und der wird dann halt da tatsächlich in dieses Bildsprachformat gekloppt. Und auf die Art und Weise erzielen die halt Leute, die tatsächlich diese irgendwie verkürzten Sätze, irgendwie Verben brauchen wir nicht und was halt sonst noch so, diese Bildsprache kennst du?
Das muss man sich auch immer bewusst sein, bevor man anfängt auf Journalisten zu schimpfen, dass ein Journalist natürlich immer am Anfang einer Kette steht, wo am Ende dann etwas rauskommt und dass dazwischen Redakteure sitzen und andere Leute, die nochmal hier ein bisschen drehen, die die Überschrift umformulieren oder so und damit im zweifelsfalligen gesamten Text eine andere Richtung geben.
Und vergessen wir bitte nicht das Gehirn des Lesers, des Interpreten, weil dadurch wird es auch nochmal gefiltert und dadurch sieht das Ganze dann auch nochmal ganz anders aus, wenn der dann im Grunde mit diesem Artikel fertig ist. Aber lass uns einfach nochmal ganz kurz sagen, wie diese Sendung heißt. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich finde es super, dass die Jungs hier sind. Ron und Frank vom Chaos Computer Club Chaos Radio. Hört ihr, weil ich habe mich schon lange nicht mehr so festgequatscht. Das macht richtig Spaß. Und vielleicht sollte es euch das auch machen. 0331 77 97 1 1 0 ist unsere Telefonnummer. Und auch wenn das hier so ein bisschen diskomäßig klingt, wir fahren das mal ein bisschen zurück, ist hoffentlich noch der Stefan am Telefon. Heute Abend geht es um Wahrheit und wie sie in den Medien vermittelt wird. Ich verkürze das jetzt mal, bin Journalist.
Ja, schönen guten Abend. Ich hätte zum Beispiel zwei Themen. Die eins für die erste Kategorie und eins für die letzte Kategorie. Die letzte Kategorie wäre dieses unsickliche Flugzeugunglück in der Ukraine vor ein paar Wochen oder Monaten, glaube ich schon her. Na, bei dieser Flugshow.
Ah, die Flugshow, also du meintest nicht irgendwie den Abschuss.
Nein.
Also du meintest die Flugshow, wo diese beiden Piloten waren, das zwei. Also richtig Flugshow mit Publikum und wir fliegen ein bisschen links rum, rechts rum und machen ein paar lustige Sachen und plötzlich knallt eins von den Dingern ins Publikum praktisch und etliche Leute sind tot.
Was hast du da für eine Geschichte?
Genau diese Sache. Und zwar sah das ja vom äußerlichen fast wie eine Kopie dieses Rammsteinunglücks aus, auch mit diesen Hin und Her-Schwenken des Flugzeugs, auch mit dieser Kameraführung, die man dann im Fernsehen gesehen hat. Das war dann eigentlich auch abgehakt, bloß wenig später kam dann in RTL eine Exklusiv-Story und dort wurden dann irgendwelche Fliegelobjekte gezeigt, die angeblich dort hinter diesem Flugzeug oder daneben dort irgendwie abgeschossen in den Himmel stiegen. Und daraus wurde dann eine ziemliche Story gemacht, bloß die, diese Geschichte, versackte dann irgendwie und es ist glaube ich bis heute gar keine Rede mehr, was das eigentlich gewesen ist.
Ja, da habe ich einen Artikel drüber gelesen und zwar auf Janes. Janes ist so ein, ich sag mal, ein Militärinformationsdienst, also so eine Datensammlung über alles, was mit Militär zu tun hat. Und die hatten sich dieses Video auch angeguckt und waren zu dem Schluss gekommen, dass es sich wohl irgendwie um einen Vogel handelte, was natürlich, man kann es nun glauben oder nicht, aber es ist tatsächlich auch so eine Geschichte, wo halt die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man rausbekommt, was da wirklich passiert ist, also extrem gering ist.
Ja, also das überrascht mich jetzt ziemlich, also wie ein Vogel sah es für mich nicht aus.
Also was hat dich fasziniert? Dich hat fasziniert, dass du da im Fernsehen Exklusiv-Storys gesehen hast, von der du dann nie wieder was in der Zeitung gelesen hast?
Nein, mich hat eigentlich fasziniert, dass diese Sache mit diesem schrecklichen Unglück eigentlich schon abgeschlossen war. Nur, dass man wenig später dann noch durch ATL, exklusiv dieses Detail, dass man jetzt, meinetwegen auch für unwichtig erklären kann, dass dieses Detail dann noch mal so groß in den Vordergrund gestellt wurde, direkt damit mit Videoausschnitten dieses langgezogenen Objektes und dass dann, glaube ich, dann wenig später, zack, überhaupt nichts mehr davon zu sehen war.
Aber hast du das geglaubt? Oder war das plausibel dargestellt?
Nein, es war eigentlich nicht plausibel dargestellt. Mich hat es gewundert, dass dann ein Sender wie RTL das dann auch direkt in den Nachrichten vermarktet und gleich als Exklusiv-RTL-Bildmaterial hinstellt, sodass dann automatisch eine gewisse Wichtigkeit dann auch suggeriert wurde.
Mein Verdacht, sie konnten den Bildern nicht wieder stehen. Das ist so, wie wenn man die Hitler-Tagebücher gekauft hat. Die haben die Bilder gekauft und dann haben sie schon so viel Investment gehabt. Also nicht nur Geld, sondern auch, ne?
Genau, ich glaube, es war ihnen eigentlich auch egal, ob es nun nur eine Rakete war oder ein Vogel.
Und dann die zweite Sache, die ich noch hatte, war auch eine Meldung.
Ist doch auch egal, hauptsache ich hab eine Story. Entschuldigung. Sprich weiter.
Und die zweite Meldung war sogar in dieser großartigen RTL-News-Sendung mit Peter Klöppel. Kurz vor dem Sportteil gab es mal eine Meldung von einem Geist auf einem amerikanischen Schrottplatz. Von diesem habe ich eigentlich auch nichts mehr gehört. Das fand ich insofern eine lustige Sache, weil es in den Nachrichten direkt vorkam und mit Videomaterial belegt wurde. Also da wurden Aufnahmen gezeigt von einer Überwachungskamera eines amerikanischen Schrottplatzes, wo eine als deutliche weibliche Silette erkennbare Gestalt über diesen Schrottblatt Geist von Auto zu Auto und es einen Eindruck machte, als würde es so in jedes Auto hinein sehen. Aber da fand ich eine sehr faszinierende Story, ist dann aber glaube ich auch irgendwie versackt. Hätte mich dann auch interessiert, ob es genau war.
Wahrscheinlich war die Faktenbasis so dünn, dass man da auch keine richtige Story draus machen konnte.
Normalerweise wäre es dann glaube ich was für die Bildzeitung gewesen, die verstorbene Frau sucht auf dem Schrottplatz nach ihrem unfallverstorbene Mann oder so.
Das finde ich aber das Faszinierende an Deutschland, dass diese Treppe, die es im angelsächsischen Bereich gibt, zwischen diesen richtig krassen Boulevard-Zeitungen, also die halt irgendwie dauernd Elvis und Ufos und diese Dinge sichten, und den so normalen Boulevard-Zeitungen, dass die in Deutschland irgendwie unscharfer ist. Also in England oder so, wenn du so das Sun oder so was hast, die sind halt alle so ein bisschen diesseitiger. Also auf dieser Seite der Realität, während du so in einer BZ oder so, da findest du das komplette Spektrum bis irgendwie kurz vor Elvis.
0331 77 97 110, wenn ihr auch Geschichten habt, mit denen ihr beitragen möchtet, Geschichten, die mehr oder weniger der Wahrheit entsprechen, wie viel mehr oder weniger, das habt ihr selbst zu entscheiden. Und denn es geht heute Abend um Wahrheit hier im Blue Moon im Chaosradio auf Fritz. Und am Telefon ist die Ulrike.
Ja, ich hab mal zusammen mit anderen Leuten, da war ich in einer Studierendenvertretung der FU, die BZ manipuliert.
Das macht ihr also in der Studierendenvertretung?
Natürlich auf politischen Gründen. Ja, das war sehr spannend. Man setzt sich ja schon in der Studierendenvertretung auch damit auseinander, wie kommt man in die Medien, wie platziert man irgendwie Katastrophenmeldungen zu Hochschulen oder so, weil Hochschulpolitik ja normaler Leute nicht so richtig interessiert und so. Und der Anlass war eigentlich ziemlich tragisch. Also eine Frau aus dem ASFSU, aus dem Ausländerinnenreferat, wurde am helllichten Tage zusammengeschlagen. Das war Mitte der 90er in Berlin, im U-Bahnhof Leopoldstadt. Das war die übliche Situation. Keiner hat geguckt, keiner hat sich interessiert und die Frau hat zwei Zähne verloren. Das war dann so ein paar Tage in der Presse, in der Berliner Lokalpresse, wo von wegen ja auch schon wieder Ausländerfeindlichkeit, naja, die armen Ausländer, so ungefähr. Und uns hat die Berichterstattung einfach nicht gereicht. Das war halt so Anfang Mitte der 90er, wo dieses ganze Thema hochkam und eben auch zunehmend mehr Gewalttätigkeiten zu beurachten waren. Und wir wollten da schon, naja, etwas ernsthafter dieses Thema in die Medien bringen. Daraufhin gab es einen ASTA-Beschluss, der auch so rausgefaxt wurde als Presseerklärung, dass der ASTA-FU bereit wäre, ausländischen Studierenden Geld zur Selbstverteidigung, zur Versorgung zu stellen. So war die Formulierung. Also wirklich ziemlich neutral.
Für einen Kurs oder für Waffen oder für was?
Ja eben, das haben wir offen gelassen. Also natürlich ist es ganz klar, dass der ASTA-FU jetzt nicht Waffen kaufen kann. Es war völlig klar, dass man für ausländische Studis Selbstverteidigungskurse anbieten kann. Das haben wir durchaus auch im Rahmen einem Frauenreferat gemacht. Es gab Frauen-Selbstverteidigungskurse. Warum nicht auch für ausländische Studis, die sich verdroht fühlen?
Warum die nicht Bodyguards stellen?
Keine Ahnung. Jedenfalls war der Beschluss so offen formuliert. Aber da kam dann nicht mehr so richtig die Resonanz drauf in der Presse. Und daraufhin hat dann einer aus dem Kulturreferat, der hatte immer ziemlich coole Ideen, ein sehr fitter Typ, hat dann also, also der Tagesspiegel hat irgendwann Beschluss zitiert. Das muss man dazu sagen. Aber ohne weitere Konsequenzen sozusagen. Naja, und der rief dann beim Bürgertelefon der BZ an. Ja, sein Schwanger hätte ja lesen in dem Tagesspiegel, also dass die Studenten jetzt Waffen kaufen. Und was die BZ dazu sagen soll. Und die BZ wiegelte dann am Telefon ab. Ach was, das kann gar nicht sein. Das wüssten wir. Fünf Minuten später riefen die bei uns an, ob wir ihnen nochmal unseren Beschluss faxen könnten. Daraufhin waren wir auf der ersten Seite am nächsten Tag. Mit der Schlagzeile Waffen für ausländische Studenten.
Das ist aber auch geil. Die wollen es nicht wissen. Die wollen nicht von dir hören, was du gemeint hast. Sondern die wollen den Beschluss und ihn möglichst auslegen.
Und damit machen sie halt dann Meinungen. So von wegen um Gottes Willen, es geht wieder 1968 los, die Studenten bewaffnen sich wieder. So ungefähr. Und das hatte dann aber genau die Konsequenzen.
Das gab es doch schon mal. Das hatten wir doch schon mal.
Ganz gefährlich und um Gottes Willen. Und dann auch noch Ausländer. Also das war aber genau die Reaktion, auf die wir gewartet hatten. Dann war das Thema nämlich wieder eine Woche in Adresse. Und dann kam als ich ATL in Astau und hatte da irgendwie wild rumgesindet.
Haben sie Waffen gefunden, wenigstens?
Nö, wir haben uns Kataloge kommen lassen. Aber natürlich fingen wir dann nicht an, dass wir die Belastung auf zu bestellen lassen. Wir haben versucht, die Medien so zu manipulieren, dass sie für uns arbeiten und dass dieses Thema Rassismus, und zwar Rassismus mit wirklich krassen Folgen, wo Leute zusammengeschlagen werden, nochmal richtig dick in die Medien kommt. Das wir ein Forum hatten.
Aber klar löblich, und dann war es auch ein Medien, aber glaubst du, dass es dann in dem Punkt Rassismus und wie Leute zusammengeschlagen werden, dann wirklich was gebracht hat?
Also, ich finde das ziemlich gut. Meine persönliche Meinung dazu ist ja, dass auch ein guter Zweck der Propaganda bedarf. Und dass Propaganda nicht immer der Wahrheit verpflichtet ist. Insofern kann ich das eigentlich nur gut halten.
Was heißt hier, der Wahrheit verpflichtet, Frank? Im Ernst. Das Einzige, was da passiert ist, ist, dass jemand mal diesen Beschluss gelesen hat und die Journalisten darauf hingewiesen hat, was das bedeuten könnte, wenn man es mal ein bisschen entsprechend hart auslegt. Und das war dann plötzlich eine Story, weil das ging zu weit. Das war irgendwie so eins so zu hart.
Ja, aber die Wahrheit ist doch, was auf der Titelseite angekommen ist.
Richtig, genau. Studenten bewaffnen sich hier.
Das war total spannend.
Also muss der Asta das immer schon so gemeint haben. Die haben das Geld eigentlich nur für Waffen rausgegeben.
Seit den 60er Jahren. Und sonst fliegen sie damit nach Kuba. Das war ein ganz spannendes Experiment. Es war auch ein Glücksgriff. Es ist mal gelungen. Also sonst funktioniert das natürlich nicht so einfach.
Gerade bei so einem Thema, wo man sich doch sehr gegen den Mainstream bewegt. Das ist halt schon schwierig.
Meine Sorge war jetzt nur, dass das wichtige und an sich richtige Thema dann halt auch nur über das transportiert werden kann, was das andere dann in den Hintergrund drängt. Also das, meine ich.
Nein, eigentlich nicht, weil das war dann schon der Effekt, dass die anderen sozusagen in Anführungszeichen seriösere Tageszeitungen nachziehen mussten. Und sich damit nochmal intensiver auseinandergesetzt haben. Und wir einfach mehr Raum hatten, um uns dazu, naja, schon etwas differenzierter zu äußern, als sonst in so einer Pressemitteilung rüberkommt.
Also insofern war es erfolgreich?
Vielen Dank, Ulrike. Zur Bewohnung ein kleines Intermezzo.
Also ich kann etwas, was nicht jeder kann. Ich kann mir selber ins Wort fallen, stellt sich, wer Wörter unterschlägt und setze nicht zu Ende.
Und im Rat?
Fritz.
Und damit wären wir wieder beim Thema.
Wir mal, glaub ich, dieses Musikstück hören.
Dann machen wir so lange eine kleine Pause und hören dieses kleine Musikstück, von dem du natürlich noch eher noch verraten musst, was es überhaupt ist. Ihr hört den Blue Moon auf Fritz, Chaos Radio, die 75. Ausgabe immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Zirn auf Fritz im Studio, der Ron vom Chaos Computer Club Hamburg und der Frank schon des Öfteren zu Gast gewesen hier im Fritz Studio aus Berlin und eine junge Frau aus einem Musikstück.
Genau.
Das natürlich jetzt betitelt werden muss, Rau Musikspiel, muss man auch verraten, was es ist.
Das Musikstück heißt Orbit und ist von einem Berliner Projekt, das heißt Lipstick und das wurde mir vorhin in die Hand gedrückt und ich hab da mal reingehört und fand das irgendwie ganz nett. Das ist so nette elektronische Musik, so minimal-mäßig wurde mir gesagt, dass es das sei. Aber es hat schöne Bässe fand ich.
Sehr schöne Bässe. Die Frau hat sehr schöne Bässe. Nun, der Frank ist am Telefon und vielleicht sollten wir einleitend nochmal für alle, die jetzt erst dazukommen sind, zum Blumen-Moon erwähnen, worum es geht. Es geht um Wahrheit. Und zwar im medientechnischen Sinne, wenn man so möchte. Die Vermittlung von Wahrheit, die Erzählung von Wahrheit und mediale Vermittlung. Das haben wir zwar die ganze Zeit erzählt, auf der Basis von Zeitschriften, Zeitungen, Fernsehen und so weiter. Aber auch eben halt der ganz normalen Geschichte. Sobald man eine Geschichte erzählt, vermittelt man im Grunde eine Wahrheit. Und das ist natürlich sehr spannend. Alles nur Geschichten. Frank, wie geht deine Geschichte?
Ja, also ich muss erst mal vorab sagen, dass ich ein Verschwörungstheoretiker bin und an die Weltverschwörung der Illuminaten glaube. Und somit auch daran glaube, dass die Illuminaten im Zeitalter der Computertechnik und der neuen Medien unsere Welt praktisch beeinflussen und Nachrichten und News und so was alles in ihren Sinne untervolk muschen.
Ja, aber wir sind nicht befugt, dazu Aussagen zu machen.
Also ich meine, wir sind ordentlich. Jetzt tu nicht wieder so, als wärst du einer von den Illuminaten.
Na ja, weißt du, ich meine, wir erzählen ja in dieser Sendung die Wahrheit. Also außer die Sachen mit den Fröschen natürlich. Die können wir halt nicht erzählen.
Weil wir sind nicht befugt, die Geschichte mit den Fröschen zu erzählen.
Insofern ist es mit den Illuminaten auch so ein bisschen...
Ist von den fünf nicht freigegeben.
Nee, wie ihr sagt, das ist meine Theorie. Also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel, das hat jetzt, also man würde jetzt oberflächig sagen, hat jetzt erstmal nichts mit den Illuminaten zu tun. Zum Beispiel der Krieg in Afghanistan. Der wurde doch manipuliert, damit die... Also ich weiß jetzt nun nicht, welche Ziele die Illuminaten da verfolgt haben, aber jedenfalls die Wirtschaft wollte da ihre Erdgasleitung verlegen und konnte das nicht, solange die Taliban da dran waren. Und deshalb wurde der Krieg da irgendwie manipuliert. Für die Weltöffentlichkeit. Und jetzt geht das genauso wieder los mit dem Irak. Da stellen sich die Amerikaner hin und sagen auf jemanden, die haben Atombomben, wahrscheinlich werden sie auch noch, das bringen, dass irgendwo eine Atombombe explodiert wird, dann war das wahrscheinlich auch so lange, wo sie gehen. Und dann haben sie das Argument, dass wir alle in den Krieg ziehen müssen.
Ja, also ich denke, dass die Annahme, dass die Amerikaner sich irgendwie ihren Anlass da schon schaffen werden, die ist wohl, kann man wohl als...
Wir stehen also praktisch hinter den amerikanischen Marionetten, auch hinter den Regen, praktisch die Illuminaten.
Tja, ja, ich meine, es gibt halt irgendwie viele verschiedene Namen für diese Weltverschwörungen, irgendwie Bilderberger, Illuminaten, irgendwie Skull and Bone Order und wie sie alle heißen.
Mir sah die Binderkinn Rechtsradikaler, der jetzt auf diese Theorie mit der zionistischen Weltverschwörung setzt, also das ist für mich nur ein Quatsch, das ist auch nur ein Opfer in die Welt gestreut, für irgendwelche rechtsradikalen Spinner irgendwo. Für mich beziehe mich auf die Nachfahren von Adam Weishaupt.
Also aber letztendlich heißt das für dich, dass das, was uns als Wahrheit erklärt wird, was wir in den Medien sehen, ist nicht das, was wirklich passiert.
Nee, alles manipuliert im größten Teil, im Kleinen wie im Großen irgendwo.
Okay, danke Frank. Tja, kommen wir erstmal zu den Nachrichten auf Fritz.
Wenn Fritz in Frankfurt oder... Dann 101, 5.
Uhrzeit 23.31 Uhr. Mit dem Wetter, nachts, örtlich Schauer oder Gewitter, je nachdem, um 16 Grad am Tag, also morgen wieder 30 Grad warm. Jetzt die Meldungen mit Kerstin Topp.
Der frühere südafrikanische Präsident Mandela hat die internationale Gemeinschaft aufgefordert, den freien Zugang zu Wasser zu einem Menschenrecht zu erklären. Regierungen und Unternehmen müssten dieser Frage höchste Priorität einräumen, sagte Mandela auf dem UN-Gipfel für nachhaltige Entwicklung in Johannesburg. Derzeit haben mehr als eine Milliarde Menschen keinen Zugang zu sauberem Trinkwasser. In Deutschland haben sowohl Regierung als auch Opposition einen Militärschlag gegen den Irak abgelehnt. Bundeskanzler Schröder und Außenminister Fischer sagten, Deutschland werde sich daran nicht beteiligen. Unionskanzlerkandidat Edmund Stoiber warnte die USA vor einem Alleingang. Das Entscheidungs- und Handlungsmonopol in dieser Frage liege bei den Vereinten Nationen. Die deutschen Hochwassergebiete bekommen bis zu 12 Milliarden Euro Unterstützung von der EU. Das Geld soll überwiegend durch Umschichtungen innerhalb der bestehenden Förderprogramme verfügbar gemacht werden. Es wird aber auch günstige Kredite geben. Gegen den ehemaligen Finanzdirektor der US-Firma Worldcom ist formell Anklage erhoben worden. Vor einem Bundesgericht in New York wurde der 40-jährige Sullivan wegen Fälschung von Firmendokumenten und Wertpapierbetrugs angeklagt. Ihm drohen bis zu 25 Jahre Haft und eine hohe Geldstrafe. Und noch zwei Meldungen vom Sport, zunächst mal vom Fußball. In der ersten Runde des DFB-Pokals verlor Tennis Borussia Berlin gegen den Zweitligisten St. Pauli mit 1 zu 2. Und zum Tennis. Die Pleitenserie der deutschen Tennisspieler bei den US Open in New York ist beendet. Der Mannheimer Alexander Popp kam in die zweite Runde. Er schlug den Schweden Andreas Vinciguerda in drei Sätzen. Die Verkehrsmeldungen A100 Stadtring Berlin, Berlin Wedding Richtung Lichtenberg zwischen Anschlussstelle Hohen Vollandamm und Autobahn 3 Wilmersdorf stoppender Verkehr und nochmal A100 Stadtring Berlin, Berlin Wedding Richtung Berlin Wilmersdorf. Die Anschlussstelle Kurfürstendamm Schwarzbacher Straße ist wegen Wasser auf der Fahrbahn gesperrt.
Die Popagenten. Die einzige Sendung mit der fabulösen, großartigen und guten Demo-Ecke. Die Popagenten, jetzt mit doppelt so viel Dauer. Immer sonntags von 18 bis 20 Uhr. Mehr Infos unter fritz.de slash popagenten. Und zum Radio.
Fritz.
Ein sehr schöner Song, der thematisch natürlich relativ gut passt. Ich muss natürlich noch sagen, von wem der ist, wir da rufen garantiert noch ein paar Leute an und wollen wissen, wie der Song heißt.
Also mein ID3Tech sagt, dass die Kombowelle Erdball heißt und das Album Starfighter F-104G CDS und der Song heißt 23 in der C64er Version.
Also ein kurzer, einprägsamer Titel. Ihr hört das Chaosradio, das kann man natürlich daran erkennen, und zwar die 75. Ausgabe. Es gibt mehrere Möglichkeiten an diesem Blue Moon auf Fritz teilzunehmen. Zum einen die klassische Variante unter 03317797110. Wir werden jetzt gleich aber erst mal ein neues Thema einleiten, darum haltet euch noch ein bisschen zurück. Ihr könnt aber auch gerne was schreiben unter 75, weil es die 75. Sendung ist, at chaosradio.ccc.de. Und wer diese ganzen Infos mal nachlesen möchte, der sollte sich mal auf eine Internetseite begeben.
Genau, und zwar chaosradio.ccc.de slash Wahrheit. Nochmal chaosradio.ccc.de slash Wahrheit. Da gibt es sozusagen immer die Begleitinformation zu den Themenkomplexen, über die wir gerade reden.
Denn es geht heute Abend um Wahrheit und der neue Themenkomplex.
Es geht darum, wie kommt die Wahrheit daher? Die Wahrheit, die kommt immer als Geschichte daher. Das, was wir in den Zeitungen lesen, das, was wir im Fernsehen sehen, das, was wir im Radio hören, sind alles nur Geschichten. Und für Geschichten gilt, es gibt immer vier Seiten zu einer Geschichte. Vier Seiten zu jeder Geschichte. Deine Seite, ihre Seite, die Wahrheit und das, was wirklich passiert ist. Das hat ein schlauer Mann, ein schlauer Mann namens Rousseau, Franzose, vor vielen, vielen, vielen Jahren gesagt. Ich weiß gar nicht, wann er gelebt hat. Meine Bildung versagt. Genau.
Ach man, ja. Ja, ich weiß. Ich hab's auch gehabt im Studio. Ich hab auch die Révérée du... solitaire gelesen, aber ich hab natürlich vergessen von dran zu hören.
Nichtsdestotrotz muss man sich diesen Spruch jetzt einfach mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen. Viel Seiten zu jeder Geschichte. Deine Seite, ihre Seite, die Wahrheit und das, was wirklich passiert ist. Wenn man nämlich die Unterscheidung macht zwischen der Wahrheit und das, was wirklich passiert ist, dann wird sehr deutlich, dass es sowas wie die Wahrheit vielleicht gar nicht geben kann.
Es gibt halt eigentlich immer nur die Geschichte, die sich dann durchgesetzt hat. Also das, was tatsächlich zu der bestimmenden Geschichte geworden ist.
Nochmal vielleicht zu den Begriffen. Also das, was wirklich passiert ist, ist das, was wirklich passiert ist. Die objektive Realität. Ich habe jetzt nicht Wahrheit gesagt. Die objektive Realität, sozusagen physikalisch das, was passiert ist. Ist im Wald ein Baum umgefallen. Und das ist das, was wirklich passiert ist. Und wenn jetzt keiner da war, der es gesehen hat, dann muss man sich die philosophische Frage stellen, wenn ein Baum im Wald umkippt und niemand war da, um es zu sehen und zu hören, hat er dann ein Geräusch gemacht oder nicht? Keine Ahnung, wo ich das hier habe, aber also von Terry Pratchett ganz bestimmt. Aber der hat auch nur zitiert. Der Punkt ist halt, ich habe so was wie eine physikalische Tatsache. Da ist was passiert, das ist so. Das ist, das könnte ich mathematisch darlegen oder so ähnlich. Und dann habe ich einen Beobachter, der das beobachtet und der das wiedergibt. Und wenn der dann sagt, das ist das, was wirklich passiert ist, das ist die Wahrheit, ja, dann kann man es glauben oder nicht.
Es ist eigentlich nur seine Seite.
Es ist eigentlich nur seine Seite. Und wenn da drei Leute gestanden haben, dann habe ich drei Seiten. Aber ich habe nicht das, was wirklich passiert ist. Oder es stand einer vor dem Baum und einer hinter dem Baum und einer neben dem Baum. Das heißt aber nicht, dass einer in das Erdreich reinschauen konnte und sehen konnte, ob da einer gesägt hat, irgendwie um den Baum die Wurzeln zu entfernen. Oder ob oben einer am Wipfel gezogen hat, um ihn zum Umkippen zu bringen oder was auch immer.
Also was man halt dabei beachten muss immer, ist natürlich, dass jeder Beobachter seine Beobachtung entsprechend seinem Weltbild einordnet. Also entsprechend dem, wie er die Welt sieht. Das heißt also seinen Erfahrungen, seinen Kontexten, seinen kulturellen Hintergründen und seinen Geschichten.
Bevor wir zu weit weg sind, sage ich es noch schnell. Ich habe es gefunden. Jean-Jacques Rousseau, der diesen klugen Spruch gesprochen hat. 1712 bis 1778.
Und der Kern von dem, worüber wir heute Abend sprechen, ist, dass es tatsächlich Konzepte gibt, die die Wahrheit nicht als nicht synonym nehmen zu, was wirklich passiert ist. Also Konzepte, wo nicht die Wahrheit das ist, was wirklich passiert ist. Was ja üblicherweise im Sprachgebrauch, wenn einer sagt, das ist die Wahrheit, dann meint er immer, das ist das, was wirklich passiert ist.
Aber eigentlich ist die Wahrheit letzten Endes das, was hängen bleibt.
Die Wahrheit ist das, ist die Geschichte, die übrig geblieben ist. Die Geschichte, die alle akzeptieren. Die Geschichte, die sich durchgesetzt hat.
Und da hat einer unserer Lieblingsautoren, Bruce Sterling, hat einen sehr schönen englischen Begriff für geprägt. Und zwar heißt die Major Consensus Narrative. Also sozusagen, man könnte es vielleicht frei übersetzen, so die kleinste gemeinsame Nennergeschichte.
Wir haben ja lange darüber diskutiert, ob man das übersetzen kann oder nicht. Und was Major Consensus Narrative wohl auf Deutsch, der beherrschende, die beherrschende Konsens auf Konsens basierende, also die beherrschende übereinstimmende, wo alle sagen, das ist so Erzähllinie, Narrative. Das ist ein schwieriges Wort. Geschichte ist es ja nicht, sondern es ist mehr so die Storyline, auch schon wieder ein englisches Wort. Also der Narrative, die Erzählung. Vielleicht kann jemand anrufen und uns eine gute Übersetzung für Major Consensus Narrative geben. Wir werden jetzt einfach mit dem englischen Begriff weitermachen. Also Major Consensus Narrative ist das Konzept, dass es sowas gibt wie einen einheitlichen Erzählstrang, auf den sich alle geeinigt haben. So wer ist nun alle? Alle ist nun mal mindestens die Mehrheit. Genau. Zum Beispiel ist zum Beispiel die Gesellschaft, in der ich lebe.
Also die Gesellschaft, in der du lebst, hat sozusagen den verschiedenen Narratives, die die Basis des gemeinschaftlichen Zusammenlebens darstellen. Zum einen, das geht aber ziemlich tief runter. Zum anderen aber tatsächlich die Basis für Kommunikation darstellen. Also nur, wenn man gemeinsame Geschichten hat, kann man sich tatsächlich wirklich sinnvoll unterhalten, weil man nicht tatsächlich dauernd alle Basisprinzipien klären muss.
Also Jungs, wir reden jetzt von sozialer Codierung, sowas. Also nur, dass ich das auch um noch mal auf meine Ebene zu übersetzen, weil wir reden jetzt natürlich von Narratives, aber es geht darum, dass im Grunde die Erziehung, die ich genossen habe, in einer Gesellschaft verwurzelt ist. Und diese Gesellschaft, wenn man es hart nimmt und im Grunde mit diesem Ding hier operieren will, diese Gesellschaft besteht eben aus eben genauso narrativen Linien. Und die prägen mich und haben sozusagen die Wirkung, dass auch ich mir meine eigene narrative Linie daraus zusammenbaue. Das meine ich.
Genau. Du bist, wenn man es ganz hart ausgedrückt, seit klein auf findet eine Gehirnwäsche statt. Und die allerdings notwendig ist, natürlich auch für das Zusammenleben auf eine gewisse Art und Weise. Und die dich mit bestimmten, in Anführungsstrichen, Wahrheiten versorgt, mit Geschichten, Konzepten, die nicht angezweifelt werden, die immer von allen an jeder Stelle in deinem Leben akzeptiert worden sind. Dinge, die so sind. Ja, was weiß ich. Vorurteile ist immer ein schönes Beispiel. Vorurteile, die man hat, basieren immer auf so Sachen, die so sind. Also auf so Major Consensus.
Weltbilder.
Ja, Weltbilder ganz im Allgemeinen.
Es gibt auch diesen schönen Begriff Surrealitätstunnels, der eigentlich auch diese Teile dieses Begriffs umschreibt. Und das alles beruht natürlich auf der Sprache. Also tatsächlich der Major Consensus Narrative einer Gesellschaft beruht natürlich immer auf dem Kulturkreis, in dem man sich befindet, auf der Sprache, auf den Archetypen.
Ich versuch nochmal, Bruce Stirling zu zitieren, das jetzt auf Englisch. There is no truth of falsehood, just dominant processes by which reality is socially constructed. Es gibt sowas wie Wahrheit oder Unwahrheit nicht, sondern nur eine soziale Konstruktion von Wahrheit. There is no objective reality. There might be a world that has true reality, a world with genuine physics, like Newton said or like Einstein said. But because we are in a world that is made out of language, we will never ever get to that place from here. The only direction we can move is into the different flavors of the dominant social discourse, discourse, sorry, dominant social discourse or across the grain of the consensus narrative.
Vielleicht sollten wir da nochmal eine kurze Ansatzweise Übersetzung versuchen.
Also was er sagt ist, wir bewegen uns immer auf Modellen. So unsere Sprache ist Bestandteil des Modells.
Nein, auf Modellen, die durch Sprache konstruiert sind. Ich habe keine objektive Realität. Nein, ich arbeite nicht mit objektive Realität. Selbstverständlich gibt es sowas wie eine objektive Realität im Sinne von, da ist ein Stuhl und gegen diesen Stuhl kann ich gegenlaufen und dann stolpern und mir irgendwie alles Mögliche berechen. Aber im Dialog, sich gegenseitig etwas beibringen, sich gegenseitig Dinge auseinandersetzen, kann man nicht mit dem arbeiten, was wirklich passiert ist, sondern immer nur mit Modellen, mit so Konzepten, Stuhl und Ähnlichem. Und die sind aus Sprache gemacht. Und weil sie aus Sprache gemacht sind, gibt es Limitationen.
Gerade wenn es um Modelle sozialen Interaktionen geht. Also die Regeln, die eine Gesellschaft sich gibt zum Beispiel, oder auch die Vorurteile, die Menschen hegen, sind halt tief in der Sprache verwurzelt. Und natürlich ist halt die wesentliche Erzähllinie, also der Major Consensus Narrative, ist halt extrem abhängig von der Sprache, in der er entsteht. Was unter anderem auch schlicht damit zu tun hat, dass sich bestimmte Konzepte in bestimmten Sprachen viel besser ausdrücken lassen.
Vielleicht könnten wir den Frank kurz herannehmen, der uns angerufen hat, weil der zu der Diskussion auch auf seine ganz eigene Art was beitragen kann.
Namen Frank.
Na, Wend.
Also eigentlich bin ich ja eure Meinung. Also Realität an sich gibt es in meiner Begriffswelt nicht. Also in meiner Definition von meinem Weltbild. Also für mich ist es so, dass es zig Millionen Realitäten gibt und zwar jedes Individuum hat seine eigene. Und das, was wir also so dann weitläufig als Realität beschreiben, ist halt in meinen Begriffen dann eine Schnittmenge von allen Realitäten, die zusammentreffen. Das heißt also, das passt in diesen Punkt rein. Also ein Baum zum Beispiel. Ein Baum, der hat ja verschiedene Attribute. Wenn ich jetzt der Meinung bin, der ist mächtig, dann ist der Baum ja für mich in Realität mächtig. Für jemanden, der aber größer ist wie ich, für den ist er vielleicht weniger mächtig. Also so mit gibt es da keine richtige...
Die Konstruktivisten sagen ja, jeder ist der Herr seines eigenen Weltbildes, aber er ist auch dafür verantwortlich. Das finde ich eigentlich eine sehr schöne Definition. Also dass jeder tatsächlich irgendwie sich, also wenn er dazu in der Lage ist, bewusst werden sollte darüber, dass sein Bild der Welt tatsächlich nur ein solches ist. Es ist halt ein Modell, eine Landkarte, aber nicht tatsächlich irgendwie die reale, das reale Gebirge.
Ja, die aus, die und dann, wie nochmal, in dieselbe Kerbe hacken aus Sprache konstruiert ist und damit inherent bestimmten Einschränkungen unterworfen ist. Das Problem ist ja auch, dass meistens denkt man in Sprache und nicht so sehr in Bildern, wo man da vielleicht ein bisschen ausbrechen könnte. Aber selbst dann wird es schwierig, immer dann, wenn ich versuche wieder etwas darzustellen, verwende ich Sprache und habe dann die Probleme, Dinge auszudrücken, die die Sprache nicht erlaubt. Meistens drücke ich sie nicht aus, weil ich sie nicht ausdrücken kann und deswegen denke ich nicht drüber nach und deswegen werden sie mir vielleicht gar nicht bewusst. Wittgenstein hat mal gesagt, wenn wir eine andere Sprache sprechen würden, dann würden wir eine andere Welt sehen.
Ich meine, das kann man ja schon damit vergleichen. Also wenn man jetzt jetzt nimmt, ich meine, ich kann dann jetzt zum Beispiel zu einem Deutschen kann ich dann sagen, ja der Baum, der ist mächtig, weil er 4, 80 Meter groß ist und normalerweise nur 3 Meter wird. Wenn ich jetzt aber mit einem Eingeborenen reden würde und jetzt sagen würde, der Baum ist groß, weil er 4, 80 Meter wird, der spricht ja eine andere Sprache. Also der spricht da dieses metrische System praktisch nicht. Für den wäre das wieder völliger Nonsens, was ich da erzähle.
Es gibt auch dieses berühmte...
Mit seiner Sprache sagen wir, der Baum ist mächtig, weil er alt ist und viel schon überstanden hat. Also durch die Sprache selber ergibt sich dann zudem eine ganz andere Realität.
Es gibt dieses berühmte Beispiel, was auch bei den Literaturwissenschaftlern immer wieder gerne zitiert wird, dass Eskimos mehrere Dutzend Begriffe für Schnee haben. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie viele es waren, aber es war wirklich mehr als ein paar Handvoll.
Genau, Schnee, der irgendwie tropft, Schnee, durch den man schon ziemlich lange gestapft hat, Schnee, in den der Stippen und Gepinkel hat.
Ja, stimmt. Also ich meine, die Sachen mit dem Baum ist natürlich wirklich tatsächlich, also auch solche einfachen Dinge wie, ab wo fängt viele an? Ist auch eine sehr, was ich meine, eine Sprache, die halt eine extrem komplexe Darstellung von Zahlen hat, also wo halt irgendwie sowas wie 57 auszusprechen, halt irgendwie schon 30 Sekunden dauert.
Genau, viele, einige Dutzend.
Da fängt man halt schon mit viele an.
Ja, wie er auch schon gesagt hat, also ich meine, dass du wirst vom Leben, also vom Anfang deines Lebens wirst du ja in der Gehirnwäsche unterzogen. Das heißt, du musst ja, damit du dich, also wenn man jetzt nach meinem Weltbild geht, da bist du ja eigentlich allein, weil jeder seine eigene Realität hat. Damit man sich aber miteinander unterhalten kann, muss man ja eine Schnittmenge schaffen, dass dann eben die gesellschaftlichen Konventionen werden, wie eben zum Beispiel, dass ein Baum Baum heißt, und dass er grüne Blätter hat und nicht Lederfarbe. Und was es sich ja dann wieder überschneidet mit einem, wenn man jetzt dann wieder zu einem Naturvoll geht, und dem das dann erklären will, dann muss man ja den wieder, also entweder betreibt er mit mir Gehirnwäsche oder ich mit ihm, weil ich ihm ja, weil man ja wieder einen Konsens schaffen muss, auf dem man sich unterhält. Und das heißt ja, dass ich da jetzt zum Beispiel ihm beibringen, dass das Wort, das er benutzt, in unserer Sprache grün heißt, aber für sein Verständnis eigentlich lila heißt. Also habe ich ja in der Hinsicht schon wieder Gehirnwäsche betrieben und...
Na gut, ich mein, muss dieses Wort Gehirnwäsche nicht überstroppert ziehen, sondern es ist halt so, dass die, also Kommunikation herstellen bedeutet halt immer tatsächlich gemeinsame Grundlagen schaffen. Also, warum es uns sozusagen ergeht bei diesem Begriff mit dem Major Consensus Narrative ist zu versuchen darzustellen, dass es halt immer eine gewisse, ein gewisses Set von Meinungen, Ansichten und Weltbildern gibt, die sozusagen das Mehrheitsbild in der Gesellschaft sind, also die tatsächlich irgendwie von einer großen Anzahl von Leuten geteilt werden und die darum tatsächlich, also das Geschichten, die da reinpassen.
Es ist nicht nur das Weltbild. So ein Weltbild ist ja statisch, sondern das sind auch Regeln, die zu dem Weltbild gehören. Also in einem Weltbild sind Dinge möglich und andere Dinge sind nicht möglich. Und genau diese Möglichkeiten, etwas was sein kann und was nicht sein kann, das ist eben auch in dem Major Consensus Narrative festgelegt. Kühe können nicht vom Himmel fallen, aber sie können aus russischen Transportern rausfallen. Ufos landen nicht auf dem Rathausmarkt, aber...
Vielleicht werden sie von Krampfpiloten gesichtet.
Genau.
Ja, das stimmt schon. Ich meine, es ist ja aber auch mit den Medien, die befolgen ja eigentlich auch so den Narrative Consensus. Jedes Medium hat ja sein Klientel. Also zum Beispiel die Mitternachtssendung mit Peter Klöppel, oder wer das auch immer macht. Er hat ein ganz anderes Klientel wie RTL Exklusiv.
Weil sie eine Abart, eine Subströmung des jeweiligen Major Consensus Narratives bedienen. Wird ja auch immer gerne gesagt, dass der Mensch nur das hören möchte, was er schon weiß.
Im Prinzip verfolgen die ja das. Also wenn die jetzt die gleiche Geschichte bearbeiten, kriegt ihr ein ganz anderes Bild, weil die das ja dem Klientel angepasst wird. Durch, wie ich schon gesagt hab, durch geschickte Wortwahl oder geschickte Bildwahl. Die eine Sendung zeigt die Bilder, die andere zeigt wieder andere Bilder. Also der eine mit dem Nahobjektiv, der andere mit dem Weitobjektiv. Und die Wahrheit an sich selber gibt es nicht. Und ich bin halt der Meinung, also das Einzige, was am nächsten dran rankommt, ist eben, wenn man sich in eine abschaffte Network pflegt. Und halt immer so viel Meinung sammelt wie möglich, dass man eine große Schnittmenge hat von allem, was passiert ist. Und dann halt die Gemeinsamkeiten kann man dann als annähernd wahr. Also wie zum Beispiel mit eurem Baum, der umgefallen ist.
Was ist da, was ist da, meinst du es reicht aus, wenn man einfach nur, also ein blödes Beispiel, du hast, du pflegst einfach zehn Freunde statt fünf. Oder wie würdest du die Kontakte dann auswählen?
Ja, das ist jetzt wieder so eine Sache.
Also das kommt immer auf das Gebiet drauf an. Also das heißt, also ein fastes Netzwerk ist für mich jetzt zum Beispiel das DCC an sich in Sachen von Datenschutz oder solchen Belangen. Da glaube ich, dass die halt schon eher der Aufdeckung der Wahrheit hinterher sind als jetzt irgendwie mein bester Kumpel vom Stamm sich oder so irgendwie was. Und dann ist es halt eben, das ist ein langer Prozess, wo ich mir das anhöre, was die Leute sagen und das dann eben auch, wenn es mich interessiert oder mich selbst betrifft, halt auch selber dann nochmal nachforsche und das abdecke mit anderen Meinungen. Im Prinzip, wenn sich das herausstellt, dass die meistens in mein Weltbild passen, akzeptiere ich das schneller, was sie sagen, also ohne kritischer zu sein.
Ganz schön zeitaufwendige Geschichte, da hat man dann viel zu tun. Das ist schlimmer als Rollenspielen.
Ja, die kann man auch nebenher betreiben.
Ja, sie ist so, da fängt es nämlich an. Frank, viel Spaß und ruf mal ein paar Freunde an und dann direkt gegenchecken. Wobei es wirklich ein fettes Problem ist, was der Frank da anspricht. Eigentlich möchte man ja gerne immer alles aus erster Hand erfahren und im Grunde dann könnte man sich drauf verlassen.
Wir alle wissen, was wirklich passiert ist.
Und zwar jetzt und hier. Das ist ja nicht so was, er hat ja gesagt, das ist ein langer Weg dahin. Der Weg ist ja in dem Fall das Ziel. Ich muss mir die ganze Zeit jeweils immer wunderbar orientieren.
Du kannst dich natürlich auch einfach auf den Standpunkt stellen, dass dich nicht interessiert, was wirklich passiert. Das ist echt einfacher. Mit interessanter Weise stand tatsächlich irgendwie zu einem Teil der Bevölkerung irgendwie das Interesse daran verloren zu haben.
Naja, aber manchmal, also bei mir ist die Hoffnung immer da. Ich meine, es gibt ja so diesen Spruch, vielleicht lesen wir mal im Spiegel, was wirklich passiert ist.
Ja, das wird aber nicht passieren.
Genau, es wird nie passieren. Das geht gar nicht.
Also wir wissen auch genau, warum es so ist.
Wir wissen auch, warum es so ist. Und da dann zu einer neuen Gelassenheit zu kommen, ist nicht so einfach.
Ja, also dieses Konzept von dem Major Consensus Narrative ermöglicht es halt, also ich sag mal, so ein bisschen grob vereinfachend über die Modelle einer Gesellschaft zu sprechen, nach denen sie halt ihre Wahrheit findet. Also wir wissen, dass es halt schon so ein bisschen vereinfachend ist, aber dass es halt tatsächlich irgendwie ermöglicht es halt irgendwie mal zu betrachten, wie entwickelt sich denn tatsächlich irgendwie die Wahrheitsfindung in so einer Gesellschaft? Und welche Kräfte gibt es halt, die diese Dinge beeinflussen? Also die, wenn man sich anguckt, wie das so geschichtlich gelaufen ist, dann haben wir halt irgendwie zum Beispiel die Globalisierung. Diese Globalisierung ist halt...
Ja genau, da wird immer viel darüber gesprochen in diesen Tagen. Und wenn man möchte, kann man Globalisierung betrachten als den Versuch oder die tatsächliche Durchführung der Vereinheitlichung von Major Consensus Narratives verschiedener Regionen.
Genau, also Disney betreibt es ja zum Beispiel mit irgendwie großem Elan, tatsächlich sich einen einheitlichen Kulturraum zu schaffen, in dem halt ihre Produkte prima absetzbar sind. Sie verändern halt irgendwie die Grundlagen der Geschichtenbildung und der Geschichtenerzählung dahingehend, dass es halt einfach einheitliche Geschichten gibt. Also Generationen von Kindern kennen Schneewittchen nicht mehr als irgendwie die klassische Geschichte von irgendwie den sieben Zwergen und so, von den Brüder Grimm oder so, sondern halt irgendwie als fröhliche Truppe mit Pickelschaufeln die lustige Lieder singen und irgendwie halt über den Bildschirm tanzen. Das ist halt irgendwie ihre Geschichte von Schneewittchen. Und so werden halt irgendwie die Dinge dahingehend verändert. Ich meine, das endet halt damit, dass halt irgendwie Harry Potter eine andere Frisur kriegen muss, damit man bessere Plastikfiguren davon machen kann. Also im Buch hat Harry Potter eine Frisur, die halt tatsächlich es irgendwie schwierig macht, davon eine Plastikfigur zu produzieren. Das steigert halt die Produktionskosten, um halt so Spitzen und irgendwie Wuschel irgendwie ranmachen muss und deswegen kriegt er halt so eine Top-Frisur, weil die lässt sich halt bei seinem Plastik pressen.
Das war, wenn man die Kommentare gehört hat von Kindern, die die Bücher gelesen haben und dann im Kino waren und über eine Sache waren sie sich alle einig, Harry Potter hat die falsche Frisur. Dazu muss man aber auch wissen, dass die Harry Potter Bücher tatsächlich in jedem Land einen anderen Umschlag haben und da ein etwas unterschiedlicher, anders dargestellter, anders aussehender Harry Potter zu sehen ist. Tatsächlich ist es aber glaube ich so, dass die Haare immer schon weiter abstehen und klar, die Verschwörungstheorie ist, dass die Klassikfiguren...
Das ist mindestens die Wahrheit.
Dürfte ich dann vielleicht auch eine kleine Geschichte bringen, die mit Harry Potter zusammenhängt, die so ein bisschen zeigt, wie auch Systeme gegeneinander arbeiten können und so gegen das große System dessen arbeiten, was wir nennen Major Consensus Narrative frisst alle anderen Systeme auf. Und zwar hat in China ein Typ einfach Band 4 oder 5... Was würde jetzt kommen? Band 5? Band 4? Also auf jeden Fall hat einer in China sich überlegt, er könnte doch einfach, wenn es so lange dauert, bei Joe NK. Rowling den nächsten Band schreiben von Harry Potter. Das Problem ist nur, dass in diesem Band am Ende Harry Potter sich in einen kleinen, stinkenden, dicken Zwerg verwandelt, der all seine Zauberfähigkeit verliert und dann vom Drachen gefressen wird.
Sehr schön.
Es soll sieben Bücher geben.
Ja, das hat sich Joe NK. Rowling auch so gedacht. Und jetzt hat es eine Schreibblockade, verstehst du? Erst einen auf dick machen und dann das Buch nicht schreiben. Ich habe echt einen Hals.
Also nochmal Harry Potter, okay? Harry Potter Figuren sind in jedem Land gleich. Noch mehr, ich bin noch ein bisschen auf der Globalisierung und der Vereinheitlichung der großflächigen Vereinheitlichung des Major Consensus Narratives rumzuhacken. Das ist das Thema Bären. Ich war neulich mal in Finnland unterwegs mit einem Kollegen und der wollte unbedingt ein Bär mitbringen nach Hause. Oder ein Elch, genau ein Elch oder ein Bär.
Also Stofftiere?
Ja Stofftiere, das hast du nicht erwähnt.
Rond nennt jetzt nicht Zootiere, sondern Stofftiere.
Genau, Stofftiere. Wir sind also durch diverse Läden getigert, die Stofftiere hatten.
Oh man, dieser subtile Humor.
Wir sind in diese Stofftier-Abteilungen rein. Und wer grinst uns aus jedem Regal entgegen? Pu, der Globalisierungsbär. Also bei mir heißt er nur noch Pu, der Globalisierungsbär, weil er ist überall. Und alle Bären sehen aus wie Pu, es ist unerträglich. Und alle Elche sehen aus wie Rudi the Red-Nosed Reindeer. Und was da noch mehr gibt aus der amerikanischen Popkultur, ist das ganze Grauener.
Da gab es noch die Geschichte mit dem Weihnachtsmann.
Das kommt später, das kommt später.
Genau. Was wir sozusagen sagen wollen, es gibt halt natürlich immer Tendenzen zu versuchen, diesen Major Consensus Narrative auszuweiten auf andere Länder. Also eine Vereinheitlichung von diesem Major Consensus Narrative ermöglicht natürlich eine einfache Vermarktung von allen möglichen informationsbasierten Produkten.
Genau, das gibt Economies of Scale.
Genau. Dieses Englisch mit diesen Buzzwords ist auch so eine Geschichte, die sich immer weiter verbreitet.
Genau, das Verurteilen wir hier aufs Schärfste.
Genau, aufs Schärfste. Ja, also wenn man sich so ein bisschen zurückdenkt, so die letzten großen Wellen von Vereinheitlichung von das Major Consonerative in Deutschland sind so Sachen wie so die Tagesschau.
Die Einführung der Tagesschau. Die Einführung der Tagesschau im Fernsehen. Zwanzig Uhr. Und damit gesellschaftliche Veränderungen. Ich weiß nicht, die, die alt genug sind oder so, die wissen das, dass man um zwanzig Uhr rief man nirgendswo an. Also zumindest irgendwie früher, als noch alle wirklich alle Tagesschau geschaut haben. Ich glaube inzwischen ist das ja eigentlich nicht mehr so.
Für Edda Simpsons ruft man jetzt nirgendwo an.
Genau. Aber früher hat man zur Tagesschau saß Deutschland vor dem Fernseher und hat sich einmal Vereinheitlichung der Realität verpassen lassen. Und da wurde er auch nicht gestört, weil jeder hat sich seinen Realitätstunnel, nein die Vereinheitlichung des Realitätstunnels verpassen lassen.
Also nicht so Gehirnwäsche, bitte nicht stören.
Globalisierung ist wirtschaftlich motiviert. Muss ja nicht notwendigerweise schlecht sein. Es kommt aber später zu, warum das nicht schlecht sein muss.
Es gab ja vorher schon Versuche, teilweise auch erfolgreiche Versuche von Kulturraum-Vereinheitlichung. Die Römer hatten ja durchaus einen einigermaßen beachtlichen Kulturraum, der auch irgendwie Erdliches hinterlassen hat, an so Kulturraum-Standardisieren.
Die Viadukte und den guten Wein.
Genau. Und diese Dinge, die wir alle aus dem Leben des Freien kennen. Diejenigen, die es nicht wissen. Das Christentum natürlich.
Das Christentum, hammerhart. Dieses Ausradieren von Verhaltensweisen, von althergebrachten Bräuchen in Ländern und durch den kompletten Austausch, durch irgendwie, es gibt jetzt hier eine andere Wahrheit, es gibt eine neue Geschichte, so sieht die Welt aus, so ist sie unterteilt, daran ist zu glauben, etc. Es gibt Länder, ich war in so einem Heimatmuseum, nennt man das dann, glaube ich, in Finnland bei der Gelegenheit. Und die haben echte Schwierigkeiten, rauszukriegen, wie wohl die Leute gelebt haben, bevor das Christentum da aufgeschlagen ist und einmal alles über einen Kamm geschert hat, frech gesagt.
Es geht aber vielen Archäologen so, dass die vorchristliche Zeit ein echtes Problem war, gerade tatsächlich bei der Missionierung und danach, was als heidnisch galt, wurde großflächig vernichtet. Die Kulturrevolution in China ist auch genau so ein Beispiel, wie man es nicht machen sollte, nämlich der Versuch, den Major Consensus Narrative in einem Land brachial, großflächig mit Gewalt in kurzer Zeit zu ändern.
Wer sowieso schon ein Problem mit Religionen hat, kann sich da auch gerne das Buch, und sich für Mathematik interessiert, kann sich da gerne das Buch Fermat's Letzter Satz von Simon Sing mit H am Ende mal reinziehen. Was uns die Religionen gekostet haben in mann Jahren in der Mathematik, geht auf keine Kuhhaut. Das ist mindestens irgendwie ein Jahrtausend gewesen. Die da immer wieder die Mathematik durch zurückgeworfen wurde, bloß mal wieder Leuten bei lebendigem Leibe die Haut abgezogen worden ist, weil sie Dinge behauptet haben, weil sie sich mit Mathematik beschäftigt haben.
Also das britische Empire ist auch ein sehr gutes Beispiel, wie sich ein ganzer großer Kulturraum tatsächlich mit einem Major Consensus Narrative versorgt wurde. Denen gibt es halt immer noch. Dieses Cum-Wave ist ja nicht weg. Da fahren die Leute immer noch auf der falschen Seite von der Straße und messen halt irgendwie...
Sie waren aber auch die ersten, mein Freund.
Und messen halt immer noch irgendwie ihre Längeneinheiten irgendwie in Maßeinheiten, die es dann irgendwie ermöglichen, dass die Satelliten auf dem Mars versenken. Also ich meine, man muss sich das einfach mal vergegenwärtigen. Es gibt ja dieses hervorragende Beispiel, was irgendwie das Space Shuttle mit der Breite eines römischen Pferdehinderns verlinkt. So ein tolles Beispiel, was halt begründet, woher die Breite eines Tanks am Space Shuttle kommt. Die ganze Kette geht dann halt zurück. Woher kommt die erste Eisenbahnspur? Die erste Eisenbahnspur kommt von der Straßenbreite und die Straßenbreite kommt von den römischen Streitwagen. Die römischen Streitwagen kommen von der Breite von so einem statistischen römischen Pferdehindern. Die Spurbereiter, da die Special Tanks auf Eisenbahnwagen verladen werden mussten, mussten sie die Breite von so einem römischen Pferdehindern haben, damit sie durch die Tunnel passen.
Das ist zu viel.
Das sind Pferde.
Das geht auf keine Kurve bzw. auf keinen römischen Pferdehindern. 10 Minuten nach 12 haben wir noch 50 Minuten Zeit. Ihr das Chaos Radio im Blue Moon auf Fritz im Studio. Ron und Frank vom Chaos Computer Club und meine Person Max von Malodki. Kennt ihr Echnaton? Das ist nämlich auch so eine Geschichte gewesen, die sich da einreihen lässt, weil da ging es nämlich einmal hin und zurück. Echnaton hat sich nämlich entschieden im ägyptischen Reich mal so richtig aufzuräumen und eine Gottheit statt vieler Gottheiten und so weiter und andere Ästhetik und so. Und das hat auch geklappt für eine Zeit und sehr, sehr schöne Kunst ist da übrig geblieben, zumindest die, die übrig geblieben ist. Weil danach, nachdem sie Echnaton dann, ich glaube, umgebracht haben, haben sie sich entschlossen, doch wieder alles so zu machen, wie es vorher war. Und haben alles abgekloppt und haben alles vernichtet. Und es gibt kaum noch was bei den Hieroglyphen und bei diesen ganzen Sachen und bei irgendwelchen Grabmädern, wo man was sehen kann, was aus dem Echnaton Zeitalter schammt. Aber es ist ein sehr, sehr interessanter Mann, der sehr, sehr viele Reformen auch gemacht hat, die auch alle wieder verloren gegangen sind. Das ist so ähnlich wie die Geschichte mit der Mathematik eigentlich, so ähnlich wie bei allen anderen despotischen Kulturen, die alles andere wieder vernichtet haben.
Das ist ja das Gefährliche, was so eine wir-vereinheitlich jetzt mal den Major Consensus Narrative sein kann, wenn das durch Leute passiert, die denken, sie haben die Wahrheit gepachtet. Weil es kann ja immer nur die eine Wahrheit geben, üblicherweise. Und deswegen muss alles andere ja schon mal gelogen sein. Weil die unterscheiden ja nicht zwischen, das ist die Wahrheit oder was wirklich passiert.
Was tatsächlich den interessanten Kern von dieser Major Consensus Narrative Geschichte ausmacht, ist, dass man darüber sehr gut definieren kann, woraus halt wahre Geschichten entstehen. Also was tatsächlich die Mechanismen sind, die Geschichten wahr machen. Jeder kennt es so, es gibt so Geschichten, die zweifelt man an, die finde man irgendwie komisch, die passen irgendwie nicht, die fühlen sich nicht richtig an. Dann gibt es Geschichten, die liest man und glaubt sie sofort. Die passen, die sind irgendwie rund, die passen in das, was man so kennt, in die ganzen Erfahrungen, die passen zur Sprache. Die passen halt auch zu so alten Archetypen, die man so drin hat, so aus Märchen und so, halt so diese ganzen Heldengeschichten oder diese ganzen, so altes Gutes kämpft gegen altes Böses oder so auch dieses Muster irgendwie vom Tod eines Heiligen. So ist halt irgendwie gerade diese Diana-Geschichte, ist halt auch so ein ziemlich tief sitzendes archtypisches Muster. Und dann gibt es halt auch noch so diese anderen Dinge, die halt so als Meme bekannt sind, die halt Ideen sind, die sich halt durch die Gesellschaft langsam durchziehen. Also wo man plötzlich, dadurch, dass jemand eine andere Idee hat, eine andere Möglichkeit, eine Sache zu betrachten, die es vorher gab, die sich ändert und sich plötzlich vollständig neue Gedanken ergeben. Also die Meme ist halt auch wieder so ein, leider so ein englischer Begriff, ist zum Beispiel, was ist zum Beispiel irgendwie die Sache mit dem Darwin, mit der Abstammungslehre.
Ich glaube, das kann man relativ leicht erkennen. Also Meme, es gibt ja Gene, Gene, also als, oh Gott, kleinste Einheit, in der irgendwie Erbgut drin ist und die als Ziel haben, sich selber zu vermehren, gibt es ja so einen Ansatz, der Mensch ist nur ein Carrier für seine Gene und so weiter. Und das Konzept hat man einfach auf Konzepte und Ideen übertragen. Es gibt auch sowas wie eine Urform, ein Gen für eine Idee. Und das ist dann halt das Mem, also eine Idee, die sich sozusagen fortpflanzt, weil sie bei den Menschen im Kopf sich einnistet und sich dann über Erzählungen indirekt oder direkt weiter vermehrt sozusagen. Und da sind wir auch bei diesem Punkt, was macht eine gute Geschichte aus? Eine gute Geschichte erzählt sich von selbst. Eine gute Geschichte kapiert jeder sofort. Eine gute Geschichte braucht nicht zu viel Hintergrund, braucht kein Spezialwissen, muss nicht länglich erklärt werden, bewiesen werden, die stimmt halt.
Ja und jeder weiß sofort instinktiv, dass sie stimmt.
Genau.
Und das ist natürlich Quatsch, weil diese Instinkte sind halt geprägt. Und sind manipulierbar.
Und vor allen Dingen, wenn man tatsächlich diesen Mechanismus kennt, egal ob jetzt bewusst oder unbewusst, kann man seine Geschichten natürlich so bauen, dass sie passen, dass sie stimmen. Zum Beispiel wenn man sich so Boulevardpresse anguckt, ist es halt so, dass es da immer zwei Sorten von Geschichten gibt. Es gibt einmal die Geschichten, die passen, wo jeder sagt, na klar, so ist es. So und irgendwie niemand dann auf das Dementi zwei Tage später achten muss.
Darf ich da aus dem Vorwort zu Fahrenheit 451 zitieren? Das Vorwort zu diesem Klassiker Fahrenheit 451, dessen Lektüre wir empfehlen, da heißt es, in groben Zügen ist uns die Geschichte wohlbekannt. Also die Geschichte, um die es in diesem Buch geht. Etwa, wie sich jeder in groben Zügen an einen griechischen Mythos erinnert. Wir erinnern uns vielleicht, wie Thesäus den Minotaurus erschlug, wie Aphrodite geboren wurde oder wie Ephiginie, na was war noch mit der, ist auch egal, wurde sie in eine Hirschkuh verwandelt, wir wissen es nicht mehr. Wir wenden den Blick und die Einzelheiten sind fort. Man hat schließlich genug zu tun. Niemand kann verlangen, dass man sich an alles erinnert. Aber man erinnert sich irgendwie, das grobe Konzept ist vertraut, bekannt und muss deswegen nicht mehr erklärt werden und wird deswegen einfach so akzeptiert als Wahrheit.
Und dieses Geschichten, also z.B. so ein Mem, also eine Geschichte, die sich auf dem Weg zur Durchsetzung befindet, kann man ja schon so sagen, ist ja immer darauf angewiesen, halt möglichst neue Opfer zu finden, also Mindshare zu bekommen. Das heißt, möglichst viele Gehirne zu besetzen. Und es gibt halt irgendwie so ein paar Sachen, die sind halt irgendwie sehr virulent. Also die funktionieren halt relativ gut, die tradieren sich auch gut weiter. So eine Geschichte z.B. woher kommt es eigentlich, dass der Weihnachtsmann irgendwie einen roten Mantel hat, und diese Rot-Weiß-Optik mit dem Bart und so. Und wenn man da so ein bisschen hinterher recherchiert, dann merkt man, dass Coca-Cola irgendwie diese Optik erfunden hat. Also vorher gab es halt schon so eine St.Niklas-Geschichten und so. Aber der hat halt irgendwie keinen roten Mantel und keinen weißen Bart. Powerbar Christmas. Das war halt irgendwie, also diese ganze Geschichte ist halt tatsächlich von Coca-Cola erfunden worden. Ja, was wir gerne von euch wissen wollen, ist, nach welchen Kriterien beurteilt, beurteilt ihr, ob eine Geschichte war es oder nicht? Und bei welchen Geschichten fragt ihr euch das eigentlich überhaupt? Ob die jetzt nun war es oder nicht? Oder nehmen sie vielleicht einfach nur so hin? Wie war die Telefonnummer?
Ja, da ist ja mein Partner wieder erreicht. 0331 77 97 1 1 0 ist die Telefonnummer für diesen Blue Moon heute Abend. Wenn ihr euch unterhalten möchtet mit diesen beiden Herren, die nun wirklich extrem viel darüber wissen, wie Wahrheit entsteht, wie sie gemacht wird und so weiter, und wenn ihr selber vielleicht eure kleine Theorie habt und wenn ihr diese Frage beantworten möchtet, nach welchen Kriterien beurteilt ihr, ob eine Geschichte wahr ist oder nicht, wenn ihr euch die Frage überhaupt stellt, dann ruft an unter 0331 70 97 1 1 0 beim Chaos Radio, beim Blue Moon auf Fritz und teilt uns das mit. Es ist noch ein bisschen was, muss man sagen, wir sind ja nun sehr auf einer theoretischen Ebene unterwegs heute Abend, die vielleicht auch nicht so einfach nachzuvollziehen ist. Es ist was, wo man auch ein bisschen in sich gehen muss und sich selber klar sein muss darüber, dass man den einen oder anderen Fehler hat und dass man die Sachen vielleicht auch nicht immer richtig macht, weil nur wenn man sich selber beim Sack packt, dann kann man das auch beurteilen. Und wenn ihr diesen ganzen Texten vielleicht mal im Sack packen wollt, dann solltet ihr eine Internetseite besuchen. Und ich bin nur für die Telefonnummer zuständig, das mit der Internetseite, das macht immer der Frank.
Genau, und die URL ist chaosradio.ccc.de slash Wahrheit. Nochmal chaosradio.ccc.de slash Wahrheit. Und einfach den Browser auf der Seite lassen. Wir aktualisieren die Seiten jeweils immer passend zu dem Thema, worüber wir gerade reden. Und da sind dann auch mal die Fragen an die Hörer zum Nachlesen, falls wir zu schnell gesprochen haben oder dergleichen Dinge mehr.
Ja, oder total verstiegene kleine Kopfweisheiten. So, nicht wahr? Ist ja schon durchaus kein einfaches Thema, weil das ist so was, wo ich sagen würde, dass ist das, worüber wir am Anfang gesprochen haben, dass ein Thema irgendwann zu komplex wird, als dass man es einfach so auf ein paar Seiten niederliegen könnte. Deswegen ist es nett, dass man im Radio die zeitliche Ebene hat, auf der man das Ganze ausbreiten kann, weil sonst würde man das wahrscheinlich gar nicht verstehen. Wir warten einfach mal noch ein bisschen bis Leute anrufen. Und solange können wir uns ja noch weiter unterhalten. Aber jetzt, na hallo, der Fred. Guten Abend. Amt, amt.
Sehr gegrüßt, Leute. Ich wollte erst mal drauf eingehen, also die Geschichte mit dem Weihnachtsmann, mit Coca Cola kenn ich ein bisschen anders. Es hat durchaus vorher schon Heilige gegeben, die irgendwie so rot-weiß Anzüge hatten. Da gibt es mehrere Beispiele. Da hat sich Coca Cola wohl daran orientiert. Es ist nicht so, dass die sich das komplett ausgedacht haben.
Nein, die haben sich sicherlich an was orientiert, was in den Major Consensus Narrative passt.
Also ich meine, die Vermutung liegt nahe, dass sie diese rot-weiße Optik auf ihre Dosen nicht aus der Luft gegriffen haben.
Ja, das hat ihnen natürlich gut ins Konzept gepasst. Es gibt halt auch solche Informationen, manche sagen Verschwörungstheorien dazu. Mir hat jemand erzählt, er hätte ganz plausible Informationen, dass die Amis nie auf dem Mond gewesen sind. Ich weiß nicht, ich hab einer von euch davon gehört.
Ja klar, da geht es auch Filme darüber.
Ja genau, und davon hat er erzählt, das ist ja durchaus vorstellbar.
Ja klar, ich glaube nicht, dass die Amis auf dem Mond waren.
Na ich glaube, ich bin da ja ein bisschen realistischer. Ich denke, sie waren irgendwann mal auf dem Mond. Aber ob sie so oft auf dem Mond waren, wie sie sagen, dass sie auf dem Mond waren?
Ja, bestimmt nicht.
Also ich fand, es gibt da ja, man kann das mal in Google einhacken, auf die Seiten gehen, wo man das Usenet durchsuchen kann und da mal dieses Thema, da mal ein paar Stichworte zu eingeben und da findet man dann so Sachen, wo Leute dann sagen, ja, nachdem ich mir das jetzt alles mal angeschaut habe und auch diese Fotos mit den wehenden Flaggen und den falschen Schatten und all diese Dinge da, dann komme ich zu dem Schluss, wir waren zwar schon auf dem Mond, da hat da ein Amerikaner gesprochen, aber nicht beim ersten Mal oder so.
Na und die andere Sache ist ja die, dass die Typen, die also tatsächlich, ich sage jetzt mal tatsächlich in Anführungszeichen in der Erdumlaufbahn waren, dass die eigentlich alle so beeindruckt waren, dass die diese Foundation da gegründet haben, wo es dieses dicke Buch gibt, der Heimatplanet. Und die waren wirklich so beeindruckt von dieser Wahrnehmung, von dem, was sie wahrgenommen haben einfach, dass es ihr komplettes Leben verändert hat.
Ja, aber das kann ich mir gut vorstellen, wenn man plötzlich ein System als Ganzes sieht, wo man vorher immer nur Ausschnitte gesehen hat, dass das die Perspektive zurechtrückt.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, wenn du auf der anderen Seite dieses gigantische Schwarz siehst, wo du nur unendliches Flimmern von Sternen siehst und du weißt eigentlich gar nicht genau, was dort ist. Und das Einzige, was du wirklich weißt, ist das da unten. Das, was du alles erlebt hast und so, das ist alles da unten. Deine ganze Vorstellung, die bezieht sich alles auf das, was auf der Oberfläche von dieser bunten Kugel ist. Die total faszinierende Form und Farben hat, was du in Space Knight ja immer siehst, eine sehr schöne Musik.
Aber nochmal zurück auf unsere Frage. Wenn du sagst, deiner Meinung nach waren die Amis nicht auf dem Mond oder zumindest nicht beim ersten Mal, wie auch immer, nach welchen Kriterien beurteilst du das? Warum glaubst du, dass das so ist?
Na ja, das hängt mit all den Dingen zusammen, die ich schon mal irgendwie gehört hab. Also dieser, ja, nicht allgemeine Konsens, sondern ein ganz spezieller, mein persönlicher.
Also du würdest es ihnen einfach mal zutrauen.
Genau, ja, ja. So kann man es sagen.
Ich auch.
Das ist das, was auch Carlos Castañeda sagt. Er teilt die Welt ein in solche Sachen, wie dass er sagt, dass die Vorstellung ist das eine, das andere ist das Vorstellbare. Das sind also die Möglichkeiten des Vorstellbares. Und dann gibt es das, was absolut unvorstellbar ist. Und das ist ja das, was eigentlich das Alleraufregendste ist.
Der gute alte Carlos.
Ja, Carlos Castañeda, muss man gelesen haben.
Ja, oder...
Genau, die Forten, die Forten der Wahrnehmung von Huxley, genau.
Oder Schopenhauer, die fällt als Wille und Vorstellung.
Ja, wenn man es so ein bisschen harter mag.
Obwohl, Schopenhauer ist nett zu lesen.
Oder Gleichsauspark, das ist die absolutste Realität, die hier auf der Erde so was ich hier vor der Haut zu erlebe.
Bei welcher Geschichte hast du dir das letzte Mal die Frage gestellt, ob die Geschichte wohl stimmt oder nicht? Wann warst du dir das letzte Mal nicht sicher?
Was meine Kollegen erzählen, wenn ich da so höre, dass ich nicht zurückhalten sollte gegenüber manchen Kundinnen, oder dass einer sagt, ich würde riechen, dann weiß ich nicht, wer das wegen gesagt hat und warum der eine, jene, die mir das dann plötzlich steckt. Das sind so ganz kleine Geschichten. Ich arbeite mit Leuten zusammen, die, wo man sagt, sie sind psychisch behindert und die haben die ganze Zeit so Randvorstellungen, so Grenzwahrnehmungen. Und es gibt ja auch diese Vorstellung, dass man eben auch aus ganz anderen Bereichen Informationen beziehen kann, also aus Träumen zum Beispiel oder durch irgendwelche Drogen, durch Rituale, durch geistige Techniken. Und das ist natürlich auch eine Quelle von Informationen, die durchaus wichtig ist. Medien, das sind ja Medien. Also wenn du Medium bist für jetzt nicht Zeitungen und Fernsehen, sondern eben vielleicht für andere Formen von Informationen.
Das finde ich interessant, weil eines der Dinge, die mir so in diesen Grundformen aufgefallen sind, die momentan unsere Gesellschaft bestimmen oder die wichtiger werden, ist genau diese Wiederentdeckung geistiger Kräfte, Medien, außerirdische Wahrnehmung, Ahnung und solche Dinge, dass die tatsächlich wieder wichtiger werden für die Leute.
Das kann man doch entwählen oder nicht.
Ich bin in meinem Studium als Industriedesigner und da kann ich euch ganz kurz einen kleinen Anekdote erzählen, die Designer von einem großen deutschen Elektronikkonzern haben uns erklärt, warum Staubsauger so schwer auf dem Boden sich bewegen. Sie haben Untersuchungen gemacht, die Hausfrauen mögen es nicht, wenn die sich so leicht diese Düsen so leicht über den Boden schieben lassen. Sie haben den Eindruck, sie haben nichts geleistet.
Genau, ein Staubsauger, der nicht laut ist, der schafft ja nix weg.
Oder die andere Sache, wenn die dem Vorstand einen Teil präsentieren, also sagen wir mal einen Radiorekorder, da haben sie gesagt, da machen sie einen Teil, was völlig absurd ist und noch ein anderes, was sie vielleicht total toll finden, selber. Und dann das, was sie durchsetzen möchten. Und bei dem, was sie durchsetzen möchten, machen sie dann einen rosa Knopf für die Antenne und den Aufnahmeknopf auch rosa und noch so paar kleine Unmöglichkeiten sträuben sie ein. Und dann sitzen sie in der Vorstand, beißen sich daran fest und sagen, ja, wenn ihr da den Knopf noch silbern macht und so, dann könnten wir vielleicht das Teil so in die Serie bringen.
Ja, das ist so eine Geschichte, die ich dir unbesehend glaube.
Es gibt so einen schönen Science Fiction, der davon ausgeht, dass die Weltelite, also diejenigen, die als die intellektuelle Elite dieser Welt bezeichnet werden, oder irgendwie 5% der Menschheit sich auf so Habitate zurückziehen, auf dem Wasser. Und den Rest der Menschheit im Grunde sich selber überlassen, beziehungsweise mit sehr ausgeklügeltem System. Also das, was da als der dumme Rest rassistischerweise auch bezeichnet wird. Und denen dann Autos zur Verfügung stellen. Und da sind wir bei den Staubsaugern, die nur 80 kmh fahren, aber so laut sind, dass man das Gefühl hat, sie fahren 230.
Sehr cool.
Und die kriegen auch immer nur so Snickers-Riegel, die sich selber auspacken. Das ist ganz cool. Die müssen die gar nicht mehr aufreißen. Es geht auch nicht, die aufzureißen. Die müssen sich selber auspacken.
So wie mit der Bildzeitung, dass bestimmte Artikel rausgeschmissen werden, bestimmte Informationen verwertest du einfach nicht. Wer ehrlich zu sich selber ist, der merkt es auch, dass man bestimmte Sachen nicht verwertet oder nicht ausreichend. Das ist das Prinzip, wie man sich die Welt vorstellt. Wenn man das natürlich verstanden hat und sich ehrlich zugesteht, dann ist man eher offen dafür, dass es vielleicht noch andere Möglichkeiten gibt.
Was ich auch gehört habe ist, man muss natürlich ehrlich zu sich selbst sein und auch sagen, ich kann nicht jede Geschichte hinterfragen, bis ich dann irgendwann auf einem Level bin, dass ich sagen kann, objektiv betrachtet unter Berücksichtigung der Quellen, ihrer Authentizität, dessen, was sie sonst vorher schon gesagt haben, ihrem Lebenswandel und was nicht noch. Erklär ich jetzt die Geschichte für wahr. Da muss man ja sich seine Kämpfe auch aussuchen.
Man kommt ja in den Bereich von dieser Gehirnforschung, wo man eben sagt, also eigentlich nimmst du alles um dich wahr, nur du musst tierisch ausfiltern, weil sonst dein Kopf so voll wäre, du könntest ja gar nicht alles denken, was du wahrnimmst und geschweige denn verarbeiten oder damit umgehen. Das ist einfach das Prinzip von unserer Wahrnehmung, dass wir bestimmte Sachen ausfiltern. Wir haben so wie ein Radio, wo alle Sender gleichzeitig laufen und alle Internetseiten noch offen sind und Zeitungen und Fernsehen sowieso. Da könntest du ja nichts mit anfangen. Da reicht die Kapazität nicht.
Filtern, um zu überleben sozusagen.
Ja, um überhaupt, um das zu verwerten.
Also das ist meiner Meinung nach schon Stand der Erkenntnis oder so, dass der Mensch Dinge einteilt, Freund, Feind, Angriff, Verteidigung und so weiter. Das ist okay, dass das auf körperlicher Ebene krank ist.
Also dieses Filtern ist ja genau Bestandteil des Major Consensus Narrative.
Ja, Moment. Aber die Frage ist, auf wie viel Ebenen wird gefiltert. Und ich denke, es gibt Leute, die sagen, rein mechanistisch, auf biologischer Ebene gibt es eine Filterung. Gibt es eine Filterung? Und das, was wir sagen ist, das kann schon alles sein, aber ich mach das eben dann, schieb ich es nochmal durch mein Weltbild, durch den Major Consensus Narrative und der beinhaltet nicht eben nur meine Vorurteile, sondern eben auch, der definiert auch die Regeln und die Möglichkeiten.
Das sind sozusagen die globalen Filter-Settings.
Habt ihr irgendwo eine Playlist von den Sachen, die hinten im Hintergrund gelaufen sind?
Machen wir es mal folgendermaßen. Es gibt hier eine E-Mail-Adresse 75 at chaosradio.ccc.de Diese ganzen Mails werden an alle, die hier im Studio sind und alle, die es betrifft, für die 75. Chaosradio-Sendung weitergeleitet. Einfach eine Anfrage stellen und ich denke mal, dass Frank sich auf nichts mehr freut, als diese Liste mal kurz abzutippen.
Oder Frank? Na, ich gucke mal, ob mein Programm in der Lage ist, die zu exportieren.
So jung ist der Abend leider nicht mehr, aber eine gute halbe Stunde haben wir noch. Wir machen weiter nach den Nachrichten.
Wenn Fritz rundum hält sich, dann 91, 9.
Mit dem Wetter, ja puh, nachts örtlich Schauer oder Gewitter. Es hat ganz schön gebumst zwischendurch in Berlin. Um 16 Grad am Tag, wieder bis 30 Grad warm. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Kerstin Topp.
Der frühere südafrikanische Präsident Mandela hat die internationale Gemeinschaft aufgefordert, den freien Zugang zu Wasser zu einem Menschenrecht zu erklären. Regierungen und Unternehmen müssten dieser Frage höchste Priorität einräumen, sagte Mandela auf dem UN-Gipfel für nachhaltige Entwicklung in Johannesburg. Derzeit haben mehr als eine Milliarde Menschen keinen Zugang zu sauberem Trinkwasser. In Deutschland haben sowohl Regierung als auch Opposition einen Militärschlag gegen den Irak abgelehnt. Bundeskanzler Schröder und Außenminister Fischer sagten, Deutschland werde sich daran nicht beteiligen. Unionskanzlerkandidat Stoiber warnte die USA vor einem Alleingang. Das Entscheidungs- und Handlungsmonopol in dieser Frage liege bei den Vereinten Nationen. Der französische Premierminister Raffarin sieht in den deutsch-französischen Beziehungen mangelnde Substanz. Er sei vom Inhalt etwas enttäuscht, sagte Raffarin beim Jahrestreffen französischer Diplomaten in Paris. Inhaltlich müsse wieder mehr getan werden. Die deutsch-französische Freundschaft habe strategische Bedeutung und müsse wieder zum Motor in Europa werden. Sommergewitter mit heftigem Regen haben am Abend in Berlin zahlreiche Straßen überflutet. Vor allem im Südwesten der Stadt ging viel Wasser nieder. Die Feuerwehr wurde zu mehr als 200 Einsätzen gerufen und erklärte den Ausnahmezustand. Mehrere Straßen wurden vorübergehend gesperrt. Stellenweise hätten sich auch Hagelkörner von bis zu einem Zentimeter Durchmesser gebildet, berichtete das Wetter am Potsdam. Und zum Sport. Thomas Haas steht in der zweiten Runde der US Open. Der 24-jährige Tennisprofi aus Hamburg gewann seinen Auftaktmatch gegen den Spanier David Sanchez in fünf Sätzen. In der nächsten Runde trifft er an Nummer 3 gesetzte Haas auf Karol Kucera aus der Slowakei. Und die Verkehrsmeldungen. A100 Stadtring Berlin, Berlin Wedding Richtung Berlin Wilmersdorf. Die Anschlussstelle Kurfürstendamm. Schwarzbacher Straße ist wegen Wasser auf der Fahrbahn gesperrt.
Der Club zum Radio. Jeden Sommer Samstag. Die Sommerhitfete. Und im Columbia Fritz Sommergarten. Samstag ab 23 Uhr im Columbia Fritz Berlin. Und wer Geburtstack hat, kommt mit sechs Freunden einfach so rein.
So und nun ein lange fälliger Anruf muss nun getätigt werden. Und wir müssen zugeben, wir haben es ein bisschen vergessen beim Chaos Radio heute Abend. Der Tim muss angerufen werden.
Genau. Und zwar gab es ja irgendwie dieses CCC Projekt Blinkenlights, wo der ein paar Leute aus dem Club und noch ein paar andere Leute des Haus des Lehrers in Berlin zu einem großen Computer Screen umgestaltet haben, mit dem man halt irgendwie Spiele spielen konnte und irgendwie lustige Grafiken darüber laufen lassen konnte. Und dieses Projekt hat sich nun weiterentwickelt. Und es gibt jetzt irgendwie ein richtig neues, großes Ereignis mit dem Namen Arcade. Und wir versuchen jetzt gerade mal Tim Pritloff anzurufen, den sozusagen Indiziator von dem Projekt, also denjenigen, der die Sachen da so ein bisschen in der Hand hat und der uns vielleicht kurz erzählen wird irgendwie, was das mit Arcade auf sich hat und wo man das sehen können wird und wie man damit rumspielen kann.
Ja, ich bin hier beschäftigt und schaffe das vielleicht dann tatsächlich.
Der drückt ganz viele Tasten da drüben.
Das ist toll, das ist kein normales Telefon, das ist ein sehr kompliziertes Telefon. Na komm schon her, stell dich nicht so an. Ach, ich hasse dieses Ding. Erzähl doch mal was schönes.
Hm, während du piepst erzählen wir noch ein bisschen.
Es will nicht? Es geht jetzt nicht um Tim oder so, ich nehme mal mein Mikrofon hier rüber. Habe mich voll bei euch lustig gemacht, dass ihr den Lautstärke-Regler nicht findet. Jetzt kann ich mit meinem eigenen Telefon nicht mehr telefonieren.
Er hat aber auch echt wirklich verdammt viele Tasten da drüben. Also ich wüsste jetzt auch nicht, welcher ich drücken sollte.
Ja, gut, das ist noch relativ natürlich klar.
Soll ich mal rüber kommen bei Tasten drücken?
Ach, erzähl doch einfach selber, worum es geht. Verdammt, nur eins. Blinkenleids in Paris, nu los.
Genau, Blinkenleids in Paris. Und zwar, warum macht das Datum, habe ich nun leider nicht im Kopf. Aber unter www.ccc.de gibt es einen schönen Link auf Blinkenleids. Ich klick da einfach mal drauf und besorg mir einfach die Information selbst. Und zwar ist die Bibliothek National in Paris. Die ist ein sehr schönes, großes Gebäude. Und auf dieser Bibliothek wird es diese Arcade-Installation zu sehen geben. Und zwar am 25.09.2002. Auf 520 Fenstern wird es da in der Bibliothek National de France diese Installation geben. Es wird diesmal auch Graustufen geben. Und man kann auch eigene Grafiken hinschicken. Unter www.ccc.de gibt es einen Link auf Blinkenleids.go.paris. Und es gibt auch ein kleines Programm, mit dem man diese Grafik machen kann. Und es gibt auch kleine Spiele, die man da entwerfen und spielen kann. Und es ist immer wieder ein schönes Projekt aus der Reihe. Man kann Kunst und Schönheit mit dem Computer schaffen.
Ja, das hätte der Tim bestimmt auch nicht blumiger formulieren können, aber wir erreichen ihn halt nicht. Manchmal so eine latente Aggressivität.
Gegenüber Technik.
Vor allen Dingen, dieses Telefon ist wirklich eine Krux.
Die müsstet jetzt sehen, wie der Max guckt auf dieses Telefon.
Verhasst, verherrmt. Aber wir haben noch eine halbe Stunde, die wollen wir uns nicht damit versauen, indem wir darüber reden, weil das sind ja nun Kinkerlizchen und ihr könnt immerhin noch von der anderen Seite aus anrufen. Gar kein Problem. 0331 77 97 110. Es geht um Wahrheit beim heutigen Chaos Radio. Zu Gast im Studio, wir sind zu dritt. Der Ron, der Frank vom Chaos Computer Club und meine Person Max von Malodki und das Telefon.
Gut. Wir waren bei diesem Begriff des Major Consensus Narrative. Das heißt also, die Quantität, die vorherrschende Geschichte einer Gemeinschaft. Die wurde durch diesen Major Consensus Narrative definiert.
Das Ganze kann man sich als Schichtenmodell vorstellen. Ich hab so drei verschiedene aufeinander aufbauende Schichten und die haben wir zum Teil schon angedeutet. Einmal ganz unten liegen die Archetypen. Genau, die Archetypen. Und dann sind wir eigentlich davon überzeugt, dass über den Archetypen liegt nochmal so eine Ebene, die mehr so geografisch bedingt ist oder durch die Nationalität bedingt ist oder durch den Kulturkreis bedingt ist. Dass zum Beispiel, was den Major Consensus Narrative angeht, in der westlichen Welt einfach bestimmte Dinge möglich sind, die im Abendland, im Morgenland, oh Gott, wie war die Unterscheidung noch gleich, eben nicht möglich sind. Also, dass man in China gewisse Dinge glauben würde, die wir hier niemals glauben würden und umgekehrt, einfach basierend darauf, wie sich die Kultur entwickelt hat in den letzten paar tausend Jahren.
Ja, also, vielleicht irgendwie zur besten Vorstellung. Wer gerade einen Webbrowser zur Hand hat, unter chaosradio.ccc.de.
So eine kleine Pyramide mit unten den Archetypen, in der Mitte den Kulturkreis und darüber dem eigentlichen Narrative der Gesellschaft, in der man sich als Person vielleicht bewegt.
Und ausnahmsweise mal eine Pyramide ohne Auge.
Wir hatten vorhin den Anrufer, ich hab den Namen schon wieder vergessen, der sagte, jeder ist eigentlich alleine unterwegs. Und ich denke, vielleicht steht an der Spitze das Individuum mit seinem ganz persönlichen Realitätstunnel. Aber der ist halt stark geprägt und stark abgestützt auf den Realitätstunnel der unmittelbaren Umgebung, der Freunde, die man hat, der Gesellschaft, in der man sich bewegt, in der Schicht, in der gesellschaftlichen Schicht, in der man sich bewegt. Und das ist, wie gesagt, dann determiniert durch den Kulturkreis. So, und wenn man sagt, das ist wohl so, oder sich das einfach mal zu eigen macht, dann muss man auch sagen, dass wenn ich so eine Unterteilung habe, Archetypen, Kulturkreis, Narrative, dass ich dann ja auf der Ebene Kulturkreis, mindestens dort, wenn nicht vielleicht schon auf der Ebene der Archetypen, aber mindestens auf der Ebene des Kulturkreises weltweit Unterschiede habe. Das heißt, ich muss eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass in meinem Kulturkreis Dinge möglich sind, die in einem anderen nicht möglich sind. Das heißt, es gibt Dinge, über die ich mich mit jemand aus der arabischen Welt zum Beispiel nicht unterhalten kann. Weil einfach in meiner Welt Dinge möglich sind, die in seiner oder ihrer Welt nicht möglich sind. Das ist ein gutes Beispiel.
Das macht sich besonders an Propaganda sehr gut fest. Weil im Afghanistan-Krieg sehr gut zu beobachten, wie die Amerikaner mit ihrer Propaganda schlicht an den Afghanis vorbei propagandiert haben. Und auch eine ganze Weile gebraucht haben, bis sie sich in der Lage seien, Kulturkreis-kompatible Propaganda zu entwerfen.
Ich denke, das ist etwas, was sich jeder vorstellen kann. Aufgrund dieser Tatsache, dass es diese verschiedenen Kulturkreise gibt und dass da die Kommunikation nicht so ganz einfach funktioniert. Das ist die Basis für den sogenannten Kulturschock. Das heißt, wenn man sich auf die Reise macht irgendwo hin und man ist das erste Mal in seinem Leben in Afrika, das war zum Beispiel für mich so, ich war in Cairo, in Ägypten. Das ist alles so anders, dass der Körper total gestresst ist davon, diese ganzen Sachen die ganze Zeit aufnehmen zu müssen, weil er dafür halt keine Bahnen hat. Er hat dafür keine vorgefertigten Bahnen, die er dann filtern kann, wo er sagt, okay, das ist die Straße, da biege ich ab, so gehe ich über die Straße, den Typen gucke ich so an, das mache ich so. Es ist alles neu und deswegen muss man immer alles komplett mitnehmen.
Man kann nicht von unwichtig und wichtig unterschreiben und das stresst.
Das stresst total, man ist abends deswegen auch immer im Urlaub total fertig, weil das alles so neu ist. Ich fand es ein tolles Beispiel, kulturelle Eigenheiten, die man sich dann so mit der Zeit irgendwie über Bücher oder eben über die Erzählungen von Bekannten ranholt, dass die Araber ja gerne handeln. Also du gehst auf den Bazar oder in den Zug und du gehst dahin und sagst, du möchtest das haben und bist schon ziemlich gestresst als Europäer, weil du möchtest es einfach kaufen. Dann macht er dir einen Preis, den du sogar bezahlen würdest, aber dann sagt er, nee, du musst schon mit mir handeln. Das heißt, der muss mit dir unbedingt handeln. Das ist sein Ding. Das will der so machen. Dann handelst du dich so runter bis an den Preis, das der normal ist.
In seinem Major-Consensus ist ein Handel ohne Handeln nicht möglich.
Nicht möglich, aber das Tolle ist dann wiederum, um Wasser wird in arabischen Ländern nie gehandelt. Das ist lustig. Das heißt, wenn du dann anfängst, du denkst, du hast dich jetzt gecheckt und willst um das Wasser handeln, gucken die dich an, als wärst du total bescheuert. Weil um Wasser wird nicht gehandelt. Das ist doch klar.
Okay, gut zu wissen.
Also sehr schöne Geschichten, die man da erleben kann. Und die einem vor Augen halten, mit was für Filtern man so rumläuft. Das ist nämlich das Tolle im Urlaub, weil man jetzt nicht unbedingt nur am Strand liegt.
Ja, eine Sache, die bei diesen Geschichten auffällt, also bei diesem Major Consensus Narrative ist, dass die immer durch den Sieger der Geschichte weitergegeben wird. Das heißt also...
Sieger, ne?
Also der Major Consensus Narrative wird ja weiter erzählt, weitergegeben. Und der Major Consensus Narrative setzt sich ja zusammen aus Wahrheiten, aus einer Reihe von Wahrheiten, wahren Regeln, die das Weltbild definieren. So, und jede dieser Wahrheiten ist an sich ein Sieger. Weil jede dieser Wahrheiten hat sich möglicherweise gegen eine oder mehrere konkurrierende Geschichten durchgesetzt und ist zur beherrschenden Geschichte, nämlich der Wahrheit geworden. Und damit ist jede Geschichte für sich selbst ein Sieger. Und damit gewinnt dieser schöne Spruch. Geschichtsschreibung findet immer durch die Sieger statt. Noch mal eine ganz andere Bedeutung vielleicht.
Ja, also das ist halt irgendwie auch sehr bezeichnend, dass man halt in Geschichtsbüchern so Mindermeinungen eigentlich nicht findet. So, sondern im Gegensatz zum Beispiel zu Gesetzeskommentaren, wo es halt immer noch eine Minderheitsmeinung gibt, oder zu Untersuchungsausschüssen, wo es halt irgendwie auch Minderheitsmeinungen gibt, die werden halt manchmal irgendwie für Geheimheiten erklärt, aber immerhin gibt es sie, ist halt in der Geschichtsschreibung die Mindermeinung eigentlich meistens nicht zu finden. Zumindest nicht in dem, was irgendwie so allgemein zugänglich ist. Ja.
Ich weiß, wir haben noch ganz schön viel Material, aber vielleicht möchten wir noch ein paar höhere Geschichten unterbringen, weil wir haben noch eine, wie viel, eine Sache, würde ich mal sagen. Knappe Viertelstunde, ja.
Und zwar die Sachen mit den Verschwörungstheorien, die wir vorhin hatten. Verschwörungstheorien sind ja so ein Mittelding. Die sind sozusagen Geschichten, die sind zu gut, als dass sie komplett verschwinden.
Weil sie sich von selber erzählen, weil sie auch irgendwo irgendwie reinpassen.
Genau. Aber sie sind so ein bisschen weit außerhalb zu weit des Major Consensus Narrative, als dass sie wirklich zur Wahrheit werden können.
Dass sie sich vollständig durchsetzen.
Genau. Also diese Mondgeschichte ist zum Beispiel ein gutes Beispiel. Oder Kennedy.
Ja, wobei genau. Da sind wir dann so wie dabei Gegenbeispielen, die vielleicht die Regel bestätigen, dass ja kein Mensch glaubt, dass Kennedy einfach so von einem Irren erschossen worden ist. Letztendlich ist das aber sozusagen die offizielle Wahrheit. Aber eigentlich ist das nicht die offizielle Wahrheit. Der Major Consensus Narrative sagt uns, Kennedy ist einer Verschwörung zum Opfer gefallen. Ja, Marilyn Monroe auch. Ich denke, das kann man auch fast so festlegen. Und bei Diana ist das noch nicht ganz ausdiskutiert. Ja, das werden... Genau, das werden vielleicht spätere Generationen entscheiden.
Was wir da sehen, ist halt immer der Wettbewerb um die Wahrheit. Also es gibt halt irgendwie diese beiden Seiten. Es gibt oft genug auch mehr Seiten. Also zwei ist sozusagen schon die Vereinfachung. Also deine Seite und ihre Seite. Und die versuchen halt aus dem, was halt wirklich passiert ist, eine Wahrheit zu formen. Und wenn halt irgendwie diese ganze Ding so ein bisschen mehr zur einen Seite kippt, dann wird halt auch eine Verschwörungstheorie draus.
Oder man versucht sich das mal in einer zeitlichen Linie vorzustellen. Ich hab eine zeitliche Linie. Am Anfang steht das Ereignis, das physikalische Ereignis. Es passiert etwas. Der Baum fällt um. Als physikalische Gegebenheit, als objektive Wahrheit, whatever. Und dann habe ich verschiedene Darstellungen dieses Geschehens. Verschiedene Geschichten, die darüber konkurrieren, gegeneinander konkurrieren, welche davon sich durchsetzen wird. Da schieben die einen von der einen Seite und die anderen schieben von der anderen Seite über Zeitlinie nach dem Ereignis, bis sich dann irgendwann das herauskristallisiert, was die Wahrheit ist. Weil zum Beispiel eine Autorität sich äußert. Weil es in der Zeitung steht. Weil es im Fernsehen war.
Oder in den Geschichtsbüchern.
Genau, ich zitiere irgendwie aus diesem schönen Buch, schönen Film Wack the Dog. Der Krieg, der Krieg ist vorbei, habe ich im Fernsehen gesehen.
Genau.
Ja, wie gesagt, da haben wir auch eine schöne Grafik zu. Unter chaosradio.ccc.de slash Wahrheit, da kann man die gerade sehen. Was uns interessiert ist dieses Spannungsfeld aus irgendwie, es gibt so eine Seite, die hatten Interesse, eine andere Seite, die hatten Interesse und alle versuchen so ein bisschen die Wahrheit hinten rauszuquetschen. Wann habt ihr das zum letzten Mal so gesehen oder habt ihr vielleicht da so gar ein bisschen dran teilgenommen? Das würde uns interessieren.
Oder habt ihr es überhaupt irgendwann mal mitgekriegt?
Genau.
Weil sowas findet eigentlich immer im systematisch Verborgenen statt, bei den Systemen, die wir eigentlich gar nicht kennen oder die nie gezeigt werden. Am Telefon ist aber erstmal der Jörg.
Hallo Jörg.
Jörg bist noch da? Ne, das habe ich mir gedacht, der Jörg hat sich verabschiedet. Der war aber auch lange dran. Tapfer Jörg, sorry, dass wir da so lange gequatscht haben. Aber schauen wir mal nach Philipp. Hallo Philipp. Ach, der Philipp ist auch weg. Tut mir jetzt aber leid. Tut euch das auch leid? Überhaupt nicht Ron und Frank, oder? Ich tue das wieder gar nicht leid.
Doch, wir hätten jetzt gerne ein paar Geschichten gehört.
Ja, ich weiß. Aber wir können ja mal schauen. Hallo, Sebastian, nachdenk.
Ja, zu dem Thema Wahrheiten und Geschichten und so. Also wenn ich so sehr mit Leuten drüber rede, über Gott und nicht so, dann stelle ich fest, dass es doch verschiedene Themen gibt. Und man muss sich immer so damit auseinandersetzen, was ist nun wahr und was ist nicht. Und ja, da kommen halt so Diskussionen über Weltbilder und so schon zustande.
Und hast du denn eine Geschichte dazu?
Ja, meine Geschichte ist halt, ich habe jene Wahrheit. Andere Leute haben andere Wahrheiten. Und man muss sich das halt irgendwie immer gucken. Und was ist, also zum Beispiel Evolutionstheorie oder so, gibt es halt verschiedene Meinungen. Und bloß, was viele glauben, ist nicht unbedingt wahr. Und dann kommt man schon ins Diskutieren, so zum Teil.
Na gut, das ist natürlich sehr pauschal gehalten. Aber okay, das kann man auch damit nehmen. Vielen Dank. Tschüss. Die Claudia ist am Telefon.
Ja, hi, ich. Hier ist Claudia aus Bayern, grüß dich.
Hey, aus Bayern.
Jo, wir haben uns auch schon mal in der FDF dran gesprochen. Ich wollte mal fragen, wie die beiden das sehen, was bei der US-Präsidentschaft 2000 abgelaufen ist.
Ja, das ist ein ganz, ganz hervorragendes Beispiel, wo natürlich...
Also aus meiner Sicht, also aus meinem Demokratieverständnis heraus, ist es ja vielleicht auch eine gewisse Haltung, die man zur Wahrheit hat. Also meine Wahrheit ist, dass ich der Ansicht bin, dass Gore der legitime US-Präsident ist, weil ja offiziell 540.000 Stimmen mehr für ihn gewordet haben. Also mehr Stimmen für ihn abgegeben wurden als für Bush Junior.
Ich glaube, das ist ein klares Faktum. Dieses Faktum ist ja sozusagen schwierig zu interpretieren, weil natürlich genau wie die Bundesdeutschen sind die amerikanischen Wahlgesetze nicht etwa dementsprechend, was sich irgendwie normale Menschen unter Demokratie vorstellen würden. Das ist damit nicht so. Was wir dort haben, ist tatsächlich eine medientaugliche Demokratie-Simulation, die es tatsächlich ermöglicht, am Wahlamt ein Ergebnis zu präsentieren, das einigermaßen konsumierbar ist. Was wir da in Amerika gesehen haben, ist, dass alle möglichen hässlichen Details, wie z.B. die Gewichtung der Stimmen auf die einzelnen Bundesstaaten, die Ungleichgerechtigkeiten bei der Auszählung, die Subjektivität bei der Auszählung, dass tatsächlich irgendjemand, der da irgendwo sitzt, definieren kann, diese Stimme ist jetzt gültig und diese ist nicht gültig. Was es eigentlich nicht geben sollte, zumindest nach meinem Demokratieverständnis, dazu führten, dass tatsächlich schon diverse Drittweltdiplomaten unter der Hand sagten, naja, also nächstes Mal, wenn uns die Amerikaner was über Demokratie erzählen, dann werden wir laut lachen. Und womit sie auch vollständig Recht haben. Ich glaube, wie gesagt, dieser Konflikt resultiert schlicht und greifend daraus, dass du ein vollständig anderes und ich auch ein vollständig anderes Verständnis von Demokratie hast, als tatsächlich die Designer dieses Wahlsystems, das die mitnichten Demokratie im Sinne hatten. Also ein hochrangiger bayerischer Beamter hat mir mal auf die Frage, wie ihr denn die Staatsform in Bayern bezeichnet wurde, gesagt, ja, wir nennen das hier eine Demokratur. Und das trifft die Sache eigentlich relativ deutlich.
Ja, ich finde das auch. Ich weiß ja nicht, ich habe schon oft versucht, in den politischen Blue Moons habe ich schon oft versucht, dieses Thema anzusprechen. Ich habe zum Beispiel erwartet, dass jemand wie Don Jordan mal sich beim Blue Moon mal sehen lässt und sich dann mal äußert dazu. Ich habe immer das Gefühl, wenn ich so etwas anspreche, wenn ich so etwas zur Sprache bringen möchte, dass es mich auch aufregt, dass es mich erregt, dass es meinem Demokratieverständnis eben auch widerspricht, was da abgelaufen ist. Da wird dann mal gesagt, ja wir wissen es. Und das wird dann weggewischt als Klopapier. Für meine Begriffe kann man doch selbst als Journalist doch damit dort nicht so umgehen. Ich weiß nicht, was in den Köpfen von Journalisten vorgeht. Ich erinnere nur an den Kommentar von Christoph Lüttke in den ARD Tagesthemen. Da klar gesagt, dass die Republikaner sich ins Amt geputscht haben. Also ich frag mich, welches Demokratieverständnis haben dann Journalisten in so einem jungen Sender, der dann auch mal für die Jugendlichen was bringen soll oder so. Ich bin 26 und ich verstehe das nicht, dass man da so lässig, fern mit so einer Sache umgehen kann. Also für mich ist das auch indirekt eine Ursache dafür, dass es auch eben Politik und Parteienverdraßen halt auch in Deutschland gibt.
Claudia, bevor du dich so richtig heiß redest, muss ich dir leider sagen, ich muss dich wieder ab, weil wir haben keine Zeit mehr. Die Sendung geht dem Ende zu und das ist im Grunde noch mal ein anderes Thema, da kann man sich in einem anderen Blumen noch mal drüber unterhalten, so leid es mir tut.
Dieses Thema kommt nie zur Sprache.
Ja, aber heute nicht aufgrund der Tatsache, dass wir uns inhaltlich dicht damit befassen wollen, was auch der Fall ist, weil es jetzt um Wahrheit geht und wir so ein kleines Resümee ziehen wollen, sondern weil wir zeitlich auch gezwungen sind, leider die Tür zuzumachen. Danke dir, vielen Dank.
Ich sag ja, ist das wieder mal so? Ich könnte jetzt meinen Kleiderschrank aufmachen und das Thema erzählen, der hört mir genauso zu wie du.
Ich kann da leider nicht gegen machen. Genau, Schreib uns eine Mail, es werden auch beantwortet.
Schreib uns eine Mail und ich schreib dann mal zurück so einen schönen Zeitartikel, den ich gerade gelesen habe. Die politische Struktur in Bayern.
Ich hab kein Internet, ich müsste einen Brief schreiben, aber ne Postadresse habt ihr ja nicht.
Ähm, keine, die mir spontan einfällt.
Also du kannst anronnen, Chaos Computer Club Hamburg. In der Shit, wo heißt denn das?
Genau.
Wie ist denn die neue Adresse eigentlich?
Lok.
Lok steht da weg. Chaos Computer Club Lok steht da weg. Hamburg fertig.
Genau, kommt schon an.
Ja, das können wir auch nachher machen, weil die Sendung geht dem Ende zu. Bleibt einfach dran, Claudia, ja? So, und vielleicht könnten wir die anderen klassischen Kontakte, den wir auch noch mal kurz nennen, weil wir nennen uns wirklich dem Ende zu. 75 at chaosradio.ccc.de, das ist die E-Mail-Adresse für die heutige Sendung. Da könnt ihr alles schreiben, von Kommentaren bis zu Fragen und so weiter und so fort. Oder ihr könnt euch das ganze Material nochmal anschauen. Das ist wirklich ein Riesenbatzen, den Ron und Frank hier mitgebracht haben für den heutigen Abend.
Unter chaosradio.ccc.de slash Wahrheit. Momentan ist es jeweils nur die letzte Folie zu sehen, die wir sozusagen besprochen haben. Und ab morgen wird dann leider der gesamte Satz sein. Da sind dann noch ein paar mehr Sachen hintendran, die wir heute leider nicht geschafft haben. Wir würden prima noch eine Stunde voll kriegen, aber wie Max schon sagte, unsere Zeitlandrider.
Landrider davon. Ich würde sagen, wir haben uns sogar gerade erst richtig warmgerätet. Das ist eine gute Basis, aber vielleicht könnte man trotzdem so eine Art von kleinem Resümee wagen, mit nicht zu vielen Parenthesen und Nebensitzen.
Wir machen jetzt mal ein Fazit. Das Fazit ist einfach. Nur Geschichten zählen. Fakten sind irrelevant. Vergesst es einfach.
Genau. Fakten brauchen wir eigentlich nur, um Stories zu unterstützen. Man braucht sie nicht irgendwie.
Das Festhalten an Fakten bringt uns nicht voran. Fakten taugen vielleicht, um eine Story zu unterstützen, aber sie brauchen wir nicht. Wir brauchen sie nicht, wenn die Geschichte auch ohne auskommen kann.
Genau.
Das hast du so ein bisschen gesagt, wie... Weiß ich, wie sich das angehört hat? Das fand ich ehrlich ganz schön. Lang nicht mehr gesehen. Wie die Borg. Fakten sind irrelevant. Geschichten sind interessant. Wir sind die Borg.
Genau. Widerstand ist zwecklos.
Genau. Die Raumschiff Enterprise für diejenigen, die es nicht wissen. Und damit möchten wir uns eigentlich verabschieden.
Einen noch. Einen noch. Einsetze ich noch um noch. Jetzt gibt es natürlich die Leute, die sagen, ist mir egal, das passt mir nicht, ist alles falsch, das kann nicht sein, das darf nicht sein. Und dann sage ich, ich antworte euch auf Englisch und zitiere einen meiner Lieblingsautoren, Bruce Sterling, und sage, it doesn't matter if it doesn't matter, but it doesn't matter if it does, because we share this narrative with the crowd. Der Punkt hier ist, ist mir egal, es ist völlig egal, ob ihr dran glaubt oder nicht, es ist so, und ihr glaubt besser auch dran, weil zu viele andere Leute involviert sind, als dass ihr es euch leisten könnt, nicht daran zu glauben.
Damit verabschieden wir uns aus dem Studio Ron vom Chaos Computer Club Hamburg, Frank von Chaos Computer Club Berlin und Max Malott, gemeine Wenigkeit von Fritz.
Wollen wir noch ein paar Buchtipps abgeben?
Das können wir natürlich machen. Ich wollte eigentlich schon abgeben an Adi Sharma, der jetzt hier den Night Flight unternimmt, aber sagen wir mal, drei Buchtipps könnte man ja noch loswerden.
Ja, der wichtigste, also die beiden wichtigen, die wir uns sozusagen auf dieses Thema gebracht haben, sind von Bruce Sterling, die beiden Bücher Zeitgeist, das heißt auch im Englischen Original so Zeitgeist. Und das andere heißt Distraction, ich weiß nicht, ob es überhaupt einen deutschen Titel dazu gibt.
Ich glaube, die sind beide noch nicht übersetzt.
Ja, die sind beide noch nicht übersetzt von Bruce Sterling. Das ist ein doch durchaus wichtiges Buch und ansonsten...
Zwei Filme, oder?
Ja, also noch ein weiterer wichtiger Autor ist Heinz von Förster, das ist sozusagen einer der Väter von dem Konstruktivismus, wo viele von den Ideen, die wir so hatten, fanden wir dann, dass der die auch schon hatte, was irgendwie sehr überraschend war. Zwei wichtige Filme, Wack the Dog, ist...
Wenn der Hund mit dem Schwanz wedelt. Ne, wenn der Schwanz mit dem Hund wedelt, Wack the Dog, mit Dustin Hoffmann und anderen findet ihr dann schon in der Videothek. Und das ist was über, wie inszeniere ich einen Krieg. Also astrein, da die Parallelen zum Golfkrieg sind so unübersehbar und so toll ausgearbeitet ist irre. Dann natürlich die Truman Show macht auch immer was weg. Und dann gibt es noch diesen schönen Film The Siege.
Genau, mit Bruce Willis als Evil General. The Siege. Was wirklich hervorragend an diesem Film ist, ist, wenn man sich die Reden von Bruce Willis als General mal aufschreibt und dann mal nach genau diesen Sätzen sucht, findet man Reden von George Bush. Der hat teilweise Wort, Wortwörtlich da irgendwie abgruppiert. Also zum Beispiel dieses irgendwie...
We will hunt the enemy, we will find the enemy and we will kill the enemy. Make no mistake.
Also wirklich genau diese Sätze.
Vielleicht kann ich auch noch einen kleinen Buchtipp loswerden zum Ende, weil meine literaturwissenschaftlichen Wurzeln hier heute Abend wieder hochgekocht sind, weil ich auch Anhänger der konstruktivistisch-dekonstruktionistischen Schule bin. Und vielleicht könnte man sich Hans-Georg Gardamer wahrhalten, Methode noch mal reinpfeifen, wenn man schon mal dabei ist. Und ansonsten sollte man dann, wenn man vielleicht wissen will, wie man aus, naja, also es ist nochmal was anderes. Es ist im Grunde nochmal ein anderes Thema. Aber dieser Major Consensus Narrative bildet eine Sprachlichkeit. Und diese Sprachlichkeit kann man gegen sich selbst interpretieren. Das ist im Grunde die Meinung der Dekonstruktion und einer der größten Verfechter. Gibt mehrere, aber nehmen wir mal Jacques Derrida. Den könntet ihr euch mal durchlesen. La Grammatologie, die Grammatologie oder die Wahrheit in der Malerei. Auch sehr nett zu lesen und sehr, sehr spannend. Und da geht es auch um Bilder. Aber ja, das wird vielleicht zu weit. Wir sagen Tschüss und geben ab Anna Deschama mit dem Light Flight. Machen wir noch ein bisschen von deiner Musik, Frank.
Das ist übrigens die Band heißt Orbjent und ist von dem Album Music for the ISS. Also sie haben tatsächlich eine CD gemacht mit Musik für die Raumstadt.